this is the beginners JavaScript course
you are looking for my name is Bo Carnes
and I'm with freak ok org in this full
JavaScript course you will learn
everything you need to know to get
started with JavaScript this course is
perfect for beginners or anyone that
just wants a refresher on basic
JavaScript syntax this course actually
goes along with the free code kappa or
javascript curriculum so if you want
some live coding challenges to go along
with every part of this course you can
check the link in the description to
that curriculum but this is a completely
standalone video so you don't need to go
through freako Kappa org but it could be
helpful also after this course you're
going to want to complete some or build
some JavaScript projects so I have a
link in the description to some project
tutorials but then after event you're
going to want to create some project on
your own that's how you really learn
JavaScript you have to create things
without even going through the tutorial
and just use a search engine to find the
things that you don't know or need to
learn to go along with the free code
camp curriculum I have all the es6 stuff
in the second part of this course and
that's pretty much it
let's learn some JavaScript
so how exactly do you install JavaScript
well for the most part you don't
actually all web browsers can run
JavaScript which is great cuz a lot of
devices have web browsers on them so
when you write something with JavaScript
it will run on all sorts of devices and
operating systems so you have a few
options for writing JavaScript let me
show you a few things you can do to
follow along with this course you could
download a code editor here I have
sublime text you could also use Visual
Studio code or atom or any code editor
and I've created an HTML file because
HTML files can be open in web browsers
and I have these script tags these are
HTML tags but within our script tags we
have our JavaScript so if I open up this
file in a web browser it looks like this
well I can open up my JavaScript console
and then in the console you can see it
says hello world that's right from my
JavaScript program so whenever you
console that log is gonna show in the
console here you could also just use the
code editor that's included on free code
camp org like I mentioned this course
follows along with the JavaScript
curriculum on free code camp org and
there's a built in JavaScript editor
right in here and then it shows you the
console down here another option would
be to use code pen if you go to code
pinned IO I'm gonna go to create pin and
then there's gonna be three windows HTML
CSS and JavaScript well we just care
about the JavaScript and in this course
we're not gonna be doing anything with
HTML and CSS we just need the JavaScript
and the JavaScript console so if I do
consult out log and then do hello world
then we can see right in the console
hello world
the final thing you could do would be
used scrim ba' most of the course I
actually recorded using scrim be calm so
if you want you can use grimbo calm to
follow along
once you log in just click the plus
button I do a JavaScript playground and
then confirm and it's gonna open up a
new JavaScript window now I can increase
the font size here and it already has
console dot log hello from JavaScript
you can see in the console right here
hello from JavaScript also if you hit
reload it reloads everything and you'll
see this pop up hello from JavaScript so
that's something interesting about scrim
ba' is that it has two ways of logging
in the console we have the pop-up and
then we have the console here you'll see
that in this course - the two different
ways of logging to the console
the first thing we'll talk about in
javascript is comments comments are
lines of code that JavaScript will
intentionally ignore they don't do
anything they're just used to create
notes for yourself and others about what
the code does so if you do slash slash
you can make an inline comment an inline
comment means it's at the end of a line
of code for instance I can put var
number equals 5 that's a way to declare
a variable and we'll talk more about
that later but right now we're just
talking about comments you can see that
this code is in color because the code
editor knows that that's code that's
going to run and the comment is
automatically grayed out because it's
not going to run we can also do an
inline comment or I mean a multi-line
comment if we do a slash star and I can
put this is a and then I can put
multi-line comment and I'm going to end
with a star slash so it begins with a
slash star and end with a star slash and
you can put as much text as you want in
between these and you can see this is
all grayed out because it's all a
comment and then afterwards I can put
number equals it they can put number
equals nine and you can see it will be
in color again because it's no longer
commented out
now we're going to talk about data types
and variables in computer science data
is anything that is meaningful to the
computer and javascript provides seven
different data types that you can use
within JavaScript now some of the more
obvious and most common are strings and
numbers a string is just any sort of
text a number is a number now let's go
from the top so undefined is something
that hasn't been defined you may have a
variable that you haven't set to be
anything yet null means nothing so
you've set it to be something and that
thing is nothing so you can say this is
null or nothing a boolean means true or
false we talked about string a symbol is
an immutable primitive value that is
unique now we'll talk more about those
later numbers number and an object can
store a lot of different key value pairs
again we'll talk more about those later
now Euler you are often going to set
data into a variable a variable allows
computers to store and manipulate data
in a dynamic fashion
it's basically a label to point to the
data variables almost like a box and you
can fill it with anything
you'll fill it with the data that you
want so to declare a variable one way is
to use the VAR keyword var stands for
variable and I can say my name I can set
this to anything it can be any of the
data types above but it's common to set
something to a string so I can set my
name to be Bo now later you can set to
be something else I can say my name
equals eight and you can just set other
data types later now there are actually
three ways to declare a variable in
JavaScript so var is one of them and for
awhile that was the only way but there
are other ways too there's a way called
let so I can say let our name
and then I can say equals free code camp
and then the other thing would be Const
so I could do a say you can't speak
wills and 3.14 now the difference
between varlet and Const VAR is going to
be able to be used throughout your whole
program let will only be used within the
scope of where you declare that now
we're going to be talking about letting
Const more later so I'm just giving you
a brief overview of what they are now
Const is a variable that should never
change it can never change so like right
up here I declared my name but then we
changed it here so it started out to be
Bo and we change it to 8a Const you can
never change it if you do try to change
it you'll get an error okay that's all
for now but like I said we'll be talking
more about the different types of
variables later
there's a difference between declaring
variables and assigning variables here's
how you assign the variable var a and
then the semicolon I didn't mention this
earlier but you end all lines in
JavaScript with a semicolon well it's
not actually required you can actually
just skip the semicolons completely but
most people recommend that you put a
semicolon just so it's obvious where the
end of the line is so here we are just
declaring a variable to be called a and
then here we are assigning a variable
we're declaring an assigning in one line
so we're declaring it VAR b and then the
equal sign is the assignment operator it
means that 2 is being assigned to B
we're not checking if B equals 2 though
we're just assigning 2 to B so after
that we can actually assign other things
so I can say a equals 7 so now I've just
assigned 7th a I didn't have to declare
a because it was already declared and I
can also say that B equals a so I've now
assigned the contents of A to B and put
the semicolon there one thing I want to
tell you about is console dot log
console dot log allows you to see things
in the console so I'm going to console
that log a and if I load this here you
can see down here in the console it
shows seven so right now we've assigned
A to B seven or and so we when we
console that log a it shows seven down
there if we put another console that log
right here this will allow us to show
what a was up here and then down there
so console dot log now if I run that we
can now see at first it was null and
then now at seven so here oh it's not as
seven down here so you can check what
variables are at various points in your
program
now I'll show you another example of
initializing a variable to an initial
value at the same time it's declared so
I'm going to say var a equals 9 so the
VAR a is the clearing it and the equals
9 is initializing it with that the
assignment operator which is the equal
sign
before we do anything to these variables
they are uninitialized that means their
value is undefined we have not set them
to anything but it's simple to fix that
I'll just set this to 5 I'll set B to 10
and then we can set C to a string it's
going to be I am a string and you always
have to put in quotation marks like that
so you can see a a plus 1 is going to
equal 6 5 plus 1 equals 6 B equals B
plus 5 that's gonna be 15 and then C is
now gonna say I am a string
variable names and function names in
JavaScript are case-sensitive
that means the capitalization matters so
this declaration here is not the same as
this assignment even though the letters
are the same the capitalization is not
the same so it's not going to assign
correctly and in here you'll see there's
an error if we try to run it because
this has not been defined it has not
been declared it's generally common
practice to use camel case so let me
show you how we do that instead of
Studley cap var it's gonna be stud
League cap var so the first letter is
always gonna be lowercase and anytime
you have a new word or new section of a
word you just capitalize the first
letter and so we can change this this
one's correct so now just go down here
studly cap var and then we just do
proper camel case and then title case
over so now all these should be defined
so we declare them up here we assign
them right here and then this is not
going to give us any errors it's going
to behave exactly how we want it to
behave
adding two numbers in JavaScript is
pretty straightforward
you just use the plus operator so this
says 10 plus 0 which equals 10 we can
also do 10 plus 10 which is going to
equal 20 if we do a console log and I
can put some here and then you'll be
able to see that the answer is 20 right
in the console 10 plus 10 is 20
and subtraction is also what you would
expect we have the subtraction sign here
this says 45 minus zero we can also do
45 minus 33 and then that would equal 12
so the difference variable equals 12 now
multiplication in JavaScript uses this
asterisk or a star symbol here
so this says 8 times 0 which is 0 or we
can change it to 8 times 10 which is 80
so now the product variable equals 80
you can divide in JavaScript with this
slash symbol so this says 66 divided by
zero we can change this to 33
so now 66 divided by 33 is two quotient
equals two
to increment a number means to add one
to it so here we're incrementing my var
by one so it starts at 87 87 plus one is
88 there is a quicker way to increment a
number instead of doing this we can just
do my bar plus plus I have our plus plus
now we have incremented my var from 87
to 88
we learned about incrementing a number
with plus plus you can also decrement a
number with minus - that means
subtracting one so right now my var is
going to equal ten eleven minus one
equals ten we can do the same thing with
the minus minus operator so now my var
still equals ten
we can also create decimal numbers with
JavaScript these are sometimes referred
to as floating-point numbers or floats
you can see this is one here five point
seven it can be anything I'm going to
make one called my decimal and then I'm
going to the store as zero point zero
zero nine anything that has a decimal
point in it is a decimal point number
multiplying decimal point or
floating-point numbers is the same as
multiplying integers so we have two
point zero times zero point zero if I
just change this to two point five now
the answer to the product is gonna be
five and I can console dot log that so
you can see if I just put product and if
we do the browser here you'll see that
the answer is five
you can also divide decimal point
numbers so in this case I'm going to
change this to four point four so now
the answer to quotient is two point two
quotient equals two point two
the remainder operator looks like a %
and it gives the remainder of the
division of two numbers so for instance
vana find out the remainder of 11
divided by 3 I can do remainder equals
11 and then I'm gonna put the % which is
the remainder operator 3 + 11 divided by
3 is 9 11 minus 9 is 2 so the remainder
is going to be 2 11 remainder 3 is 2 the
remainder operator is often used to
determine if a number is even or odd if
you can divide a number by 2 and the
remainder is 0 that means the number is
even
it's common to want to add a number to a
variable like this the a equals a plus
12 well ace are three plus 12 is 15 so
just adding 12 to whatever a is here
we're adding 9 to whatever it B is he
were adding 7 to whatever C is this is
such a common pattern that there's a
shortcut to do the same thing it's the
plus equals operator so instead of a
equals a plus 12 we can do a plus equals
12 so this equals the same thing so
instead of B equals 9 plus B we can do B
plus equals 9 so now we're adding the
value to the variable and assigning the
answer to that variable so again here we
can do plus equal 7 so that's just a
shortcut
previously we learned about plus equals
well minus equals does the same thing
but subtracting so this says a equals a
minus 6 we started at 11 minus 6 is
going to be 5 so the new a is gonna be 5
but we can shorten that instead of a
equals a minus 6 we can do - equals this
is just a shortcut that JavaScript has
that means the same thing
that means a equals a minus 6 but it's
just shortened same here so we can do
minus equals 15 C equals C minus 1 we
can do C minus equals 1 so it just
subtracts the number from the original
value and then assigns that new value to
the variable
here we have a equals a times five well
we can do the same thing as before we
can shorten this to a x equals five so
that means the same thing here we can do
a x equals three and then C equals C
times ten we can shorten this to C times
equal 10 and that's another shortcut for
JavaScript
and there's also divide equal so a
equals a divided by 12 we can do a
divided by equal 12 and here we can just
do divided by equal 4 or divided by
equal 11 so another way of just dividing
the variable by a new number and
assigning that answer to the variable
we've already mentioned strings a little
bit but anytime you have some character
surrounded by quotation marks they can
either be single quotation marks double
quotation marks or backticks it's a
string these are called string literals
and you can create them just like you
see above I'm going to do a few more so
far my first aim equals bow and VAR my
last name equals Karns so that's how you
create a string in JavaScript
sometimes your strain contains the quote
symbol now normally the quotes identify
the beginning and the ending of the
string but what if you have something
like this I am a double quoted spring
inside double quotes so I'm actually
trying to use these quotes right inside
the string but the JavaScript doesn't
know what to do about it
it thinks that this is that it thinks
that this is the whole string when it
sees the first quote inside the string
it thinks R at the end of the string so
there's something called an escape
character so if you want to escape a
quote that means it will no longer be
considered the end of the string I'm
going to put a backslash so if I put a
backslash before each of these quotation
marks JavaScript no longer interprets it
as being the last character in the
string so now you can see this is a full
string and then if I log this out
console dot log and I put my string
you'll see that it's not going to show
the quotation marks so I mean it's not
going to show the slash the back slashes
it shows the quotation marks without the
back slashes because when we put
backslash quotation mark javascript
knows that this should just mean a
quotation mark
we talked about escaping a quote
character like this where you put a
backslash before the quote character so
javascript knows that this is supposed
to be a literal quote character inside
the string however you're not going to
have to escape quote characters very
often because there are other methods of
accomplishing the same thing of having a
quote character within a string so a
common way is to use instead of having
your strings start with double quotes
have it start with a single quote so a
string can either be surrounded by
single quotes or double quotes so this
time we're just going to have single
quotes and now I can remove all these
escape characters from inside the string
here okay so now you can see that
JavaScript still knows it knows that
this is a string even though it has
these double quotes inside an additional
thing you could do is use backticks so
if I put a back ticks before at the
beginning of the end of the string
now I actually can use single quotes and
double quotes both within the string but
right now I'm just gonna focus on
showing you the double quotes or the
single quotes with the double quotes
inside
we talked about escaping a double quote
character by using the backslash before
the double quote there's actually quite
a few other things you can escape out
you can escape out a single quote
character you can escape out a backslash
in fact anytime you're gonna use a
backslash you're gonna have to put two
backslashes so the JavaScript knows that
you're not trying to escape a character
you can also add a new line character or
a carriage return a tab a backspace or a
form feed all with doing a slash in the
corresponding letter here so let me show
you an example I'm going to put a var my
string equals and we're gonna make a
multi-line string so we're gonna have
the first line and now I'm going to put
backslash in to add a a second line and
then I'm going to put a tab so backslash
T for the tab and backslash backslash to
add a backslash now it's going to say
second line now I'll do backslash and
then I'll just say third line and if I
were able to log out all that you would
see three different lines and you would
see the tab and then the backslash
character
you can concatenate strings with the
plus operator you can see here that we
have two strings I come first and I come
second they've been added together or
concatenated with this so the are STR
our string is now one long string that
says I come first I come second I'll
give you another example here so we can
say my string equals this is the start
and then I'm going to put a space before
the in quotation mark because when these
get concatenated together we want there
to be a space between these two
sentences and I'll say this is the end
now let's just see what that looks like
I'll do a consult out log and do a my
string and let's see if I run this we
can see this is the start this is the
end just one long string
you could also concatenate strings using
the plus equal operator you can see here
in this example we have the AR string
equals I come first and then we have the
AR string plus equals I comes second
so remember just like in when you're
using numbers plus equals means that you
take whatever is on the end here and add
it to the variable so we've just added I
come second on to the end of I come
first let's do another example down here
my string equals this is the first
sentence and then I'll put a space at
the end because we're gonna do my string
and I'll hear oh I'll do the plus equals
this is the second sentence now if I
just do a console that log here of my
string we should see that those
sentences have gone together this is the
first sentence this is the second
sentence good
you can concatenate strings together
with variables you can see here our name
freako camp hello our name is and then
we add this variable the our name
variable which is freako camp hello our
name is freako camp how are you well
we're gonna do the same thing down here
so I'm gonna do my name equals o and
then my string is going to equal mine
name is and then I'm going to add the
variable name which is myname and then
I'll continue the string here hopes that
supposed to be a plus here and I am well
see that I put a space here and here
because you have to make sure you put
appropriate spaces in and let's see what
that looks like I'll do a consult out
log and I'll just put my string here if
I show that my name is Bo and I am well
looks good
you can append variables to strings with
this plus equals operator you can see
with this variable and adjective which
is set to the word awesome and then we
have another variable freako camp is and
we have the our string variable plus
equal an adjective so now our string is
going to equal freako camp is awesome so
let me show you another example we're
going to say some adjective equals worth
while and now I'm going to use the plus
equal so my STR plus equals and then I
can put some adjectives so now after we
do the my string plus equals some
adjective my string is going to say
learning to code is worthwhile
sometimes you want to find the length of
a string javascript makes this easy so
we have the first name is set to a de
but we just use the dot length property
to find the length so first name dot
length remember our first name is Ana
here and then dot length will return an
integer a number that has the number of
characters in the string so that will be
three so let's try this again here's
another example
last name length equals last name we
just have to type in dot length and just
to show you let me console that log that
and you'll be able to see if I put in
last name length and if I run that
you'll see eight because there are eight
characters in the word Lovelace
bracket notation is a way to get a
character at a specific index within a
string so you can see right here we have
the first name adda and right here we
have first name and then here's the
bracken notation you can see there's
brackets with a number inside so most
modern programming languages like
JavaScript don't start counting at one
like humans do they start at zero which
is called zero-based indexing so with
the number zero that refers to the in
the first index of this string which
would be the a so the a would be zero D
is one and then a is two so this first
letter of first name if we do first name
with the bracket notation with a zero
that's gonna equal a so let me show you
another example let's say we want to get
the first letter of the last name again
I'm just gonna do the bracket notation
and put a zero here if I wanted the
second letter the oh I will put a 1 here
so if I console that log we can see what
it came up with so console that log
first letter of last name and if we look
in the console l because the first
letter of the last name is L
strings are immutable meaning they
cannot be altered once created this does
not mean that they cannot be changed
just that the individual characters of a
string literal cannot be changed so look
at this example my string and then we're
going to use bracket notation to choose
the first letter so it currently says
jello world we want the first letter to
change to an H to say hello world but if
I run that there's going to be an error
because of the immutability of strings
now we can still change this to hello
world but we can't just change an
individual letter like that so we're
gonna have to do my string equals and
I'm just gonna have to type in the whole
thing which is hello world and now it we
will change to the word hello world
you can use bracket notation to get any
character position in a string so
earlier we did the first position but
here's how you would get the second
position
remember the zero index so one is the
second position zero is the first
position we can also get the third
letter of the last name using the
brackets we'll just put two in the
brackets to get the third letter of the
last name
you can also use bracket notation to
find the last letter in a string even if
you don't know how many letters are on
the string you do it based on the length
so if you look right here in the
brackets we have a expression to be
evaluated first name dot length minus
one so the length is 3 3 minus 1 is 2
the reason why we're doing a minus 1 is
because remember we count starting at 0
so the length minus 1 is going to be the
last index of the name so we can do that
same thing here to get the last letter
of the last name I can just do last name
dot length minus 1 and that's going to
get the last letter of the last name
which is the e right here
we saw how to use bracket notation to
get the last letter of a string you can
also do the third to last letter or
fourth to last letter
so you just subtract however much you
want from the for the the length of the
string so we have the bracket notation
first name that length minus three
that's going to get the third to last
letter so we want the second-to-last
letter into this variable here we do
something similar we just do last name
dot length and then we're gonna subtract
two to get the second to last character
of the string
we are going to use our knowledge of
strings to build a mad libs style word
game in a mad lib game you are provided
sentences with some missing words like
nouns verbs adjectives and adverbs and
then you fill in the missing pieces with
words of your choice to make a sentence
that could be funny and hopefully makes
a little bit of sense so let me show you
how you do this
um this also uses a function now we
haven't talked about functions yet I'm
gonna explain those more later but
format for now just go with it because
that's not the point of this lesson for
now but this function called word blanks
you can call the function and you have
to pass in certain types of words you
pass in a noun an adjective a verb and
an adverb so down here you can see that
we're calling the function called word
blanks that's the function name here and
we're passing on a noun an adjective a
verb and an adverb so the point is that
we are going to use all these words that
are passed in to make a sentence so we
know that var result equals an empty
string at first and then we have to use
all these words and result and then the
result is going to be returned from this
function and eventually we'll be logged
out onto the screen with this console
dot log so what I'm gonna do here is do
result plus M equals we're gonna use the
plus equals to add something to this
result using all the noun the adjective
the verb and the adverb so let's see
it's gonna say the and we'll use the
adjective I adjective this case will be
the big a big and then let's put the
noun my noun because adjectives are
words that describe nouns a big
and then we're gonna say what this now
is doing the verb my verb the big dog
ran and then what where does he run to
to the store and then we're going to add
oh we need a space here so there's a
space between this to the store and then
we're going to add the final adverb so
now we have to add a period and there's
one more thing we have to add or a few
more things so right now it's my
adjective my noun my verb and there's no
spaces in between those so if I run that
you can see what that's gonna look like
in the console it just said big Don big
dog ran with no spaces so we're gonna
have to add some spaces in here also
let's do that now it's going to take in
the noun adjective verb an adverb and
then put it into that sentence so one
cool thing is we can actually pass in
some different words so like friends
let's if I copy this I'm going to paste
it instead of dog I will put for the
noun bike and an adjective
I'll put slow and then for the verb I'll
put flew and the adverb I'll put slowly
and now if we look in the console we
have to work two sentences the big dog
ran to the store quickly the slow bike
flew to the store slowly
arrays allow you to store several pieces
of data in one place so look at this
example our array now arrays always
start with a bracket and then end with a
bracket to show the beginning and ending
of the array and every element in the
array is separated by a comma
so you can see here we the first element
is a string the second element is a
number and you can have more and more
elements you just put comma and you can
keep adding elements and the elements
can be any data type you can see here we
have a string and a number but you can
always also use arrays or floating
numbers or really any sort of other data
type in your array so let's see another
example so let's do my array Quincy and
then for a number we'll do one because
Quincy is number one
when one of the elements in an array is
another array that's called a nested
array or a multi-dimensional array you
can see here's the beginning of the
array and here's end of the array but
the first element in this array is
another array with two elements of its
own same with here the second element is
an array so this is two arrays within
another array so we can do that here
here's another example
so let's our first element in the array
will be an array with a string and a
number and then I'll put a comma that
put the second element of the array
which will be another array with a
string and a number
earlier we learned how to use bracket
notation to find a specific index in a
string you can do the same thing with
arrays so look at this array our array
we have three elements 50 60 70 and
these have the indexes 0 1 2 so with
this our array with the bracket notation
in the 0 that's going to be index 1
which is going to equal 50 so we can do
the same thing here my array equals 50
60 70 so let's try to find the first
element that array so var are my data
equals my array and then I'm going to do
index 0 I could do index 1 index 2 and
then if we console dot log that we can
see for sure what that is so if I put my
data and we can see in the console it's
50
you can use array indexes to modify
arrays now we try to do this earlier
with strings using bracket notation and
we were not able to modify a string
using bracket notation but with arrays
you can so the original array is 1864 99
and then we're gonna use the array index
of 1 now 1 is going to be the second
number or 0 1 2 and this number 64 is
going to be set to 45 so the new array
is gonna be 1845 99 let's try it again
with this 1864 99 so let's do my array
and then instead of doing the first the
second digit I'm gonna do the first
digit and the array the first index
which would be index 0 and I will say
equals 45 so now this array has been
updated so if I do console that log and
then through my array will see that the
array is now 45 64 99
you can also use bracket notation to
select an element in a multi-dimensional
or array of arrays so you can see this
array here we have our outer array but
inside that array are more arrays the
elements of the array or other arrays
and the last element of the array
actually has an array in this so this is
a three-layer deep array right here so
to access an array of arrays or an
element within an array that's within an
array you use a double bracket notation
so if you see this example here my array
the first bracket is 0 that's gonna get
the first element in the array which
would be right here and then that
element is an array so the second
bracket would be the index of the array
within the array so this 0 will point to
here so let's try to figure out how we
can select a value equal to 8 well let's
see I see an eight right here so let's
figure out what this first number should
be well let's count 0 1 2 so the third
array would be index 2 now when you want
to go 0 1 now if you index 1 to get the
second number in the third array so
let's test to see if that equals 8 so
I'll do a consult out log and then do my
data here and we'll see if that equals 8
that does we did it
you can append data to the end of an
array with the push function so see an
array has been set up here our array
Stimpson J cat and then we take our
array right here and use the push
function to push into the next Elm in
the array another array here so now it's
going to look like this we can see at
the end of the original array we've
pushed this other array at the end so
let's try it again down here we have my
array and you can see what we have
each Elm in the array is another array
so I am going to do my array dot push
and then I can push something on the end
here which will be like above another
array so this is gonna say dog I'm a 3
and now we've pushed this on to the
array
we can remove an item from an array with
the pop function here so see this pop
here and then we know it's a function
because of the parentheses at the end of
the word pop so the array starts with
one two three so now we do this our
array dot pop and it's going to return
the it's going to remove the last
element which is the three and then it's
gonna put it right into this variable
here so now as you can see down here
remove from our array now equals three
and then our array is gonna equal one
two because the three has been popped
off so we can do the same thing here so
remove from my array equals and I'm
going to do my array dot pop and we can
see what the array is gonna equal now if
I just do console dot log I array and if
you do this we can see that the array
only has the one item the one array
instead of the two arrays
the shift function is very similar to
the pop function except it removes the
first element of the array instead of
the final element so we see the shift
function on the end of the array here
and the array is the same as before but
now the first element Stimpson is being
removed as we shift off the first
element the array is going to equal J
cat and the removed from our array is
gonna equal Stimpson so let's do another
example down here we're gonna do a shift
again so I'm gonna do equals my array
shift and now my array is just going to
equal dog 3 and the remove from my array
is going to equal John 23
the unshifted is similar to the push
array function while push adds an
element to the end of the array on shift
adds an element to the beginning of the
array so let's look through this example
code we have the array Stimpson J cat
we're going to shift off the first
element remove the first element so our
array is J cat now we're gonna unshifted
an element at the beginning which is the
string happy so the array will now be
happy
J can't so let's try again this time the
array is john xxiii dog 3 because of the
shift we've shifted off the John 23 and
now I'm going to unshifted on shift now
we're going to add something to the
beginning of the array we'll do Paul
35 so now the array is this going to be
Paul 35 dog 3
let me give you another example of
nested arrays this will be a shopping
list so inside this array we're going to
have another array and we're gonna have
items cereal how many boxes three boxes
we also need some milk let's get two
cartons of milk let's get some bananas
three bunches of three bananas we'll
also get some juice two containers of
juice and finally we will get some eggs
we'll get 12 eggs and now we've created
an array of arrays which is our shopping
list
functions allow us to create reusable
code in JavaScript this is how a
function is set up we have the word
function then we have the function name
there's always parentheses here and you
can pass information into the
parentheses we'll talk about that later
and then we have these curly brackets so
that this is the opening curly bracket
and then we have the closing curly
bracket and everything inside the curly
bracket is run anytime the function is
called or invoked so here the function
is being called by just putting the
function name with parentheses after the
name so every time this function is
called just like this the console is
gonna say hey a world so if we load the
console right now you can see it says
hey a world and if I just copy this and
paste a few times we'll see that it's
going to say hey world hey world hey
world in the console since we have run
the function three times we see the
words hey a world three times so now I'm
going to create my own function that's
going to be very similar
so the function be usable function and
this time it's gonna say something
slightly different it's going to say hi
world
it's the heya world and now I can call
the function down here just like this
reusable function oh forgot to put the
parenthesis that's important
nice hey world and hi world in the
console
parameters are variables that act as
placeholders for the values that are to
be input to a function when it is called
so we have defined a function right here
called our function with arms and inside
the parenthesis we see the letters A and
B now these can be any name that we
could call these anything not just a and
B they could really be any words up here
and that means that when this function
is called we're going to pass data into
the function or input data into the
function so you can see the example here
where we're calling the function and
instead of saying a and B in the
parenthesis we're actually passing the
values 10 and 5 so when the function
runs it can use the information that's
passed into the function so in this case
it says console dot log a minus B well
that's going to be 10 minus 5 because
the numbers 10 and 5 have been passed
into the function and that's going to
output 5 so I'm going to create a
function that's very similar to that
function this one is going to be called
function with Arg
and it's also going to accept an A and B
but we could call that anything we want
and inside instead of subtracting a
minus B we're going to do a plus B now
I'm just going to call this function
function with our and I'll pass in 10
and 5 and let's see what that looks like
in the console so first it output 5 for
this one then an output a 10 for this
one
scope refers to the visibility of
variables variables which are defined
outside of a function block have global
scope global scope means they can be
seen everywhere in your JavaScript code
for instance I'm going to declare a
variable right here called my global
I'll set it to 10 now since this is set
outside of a function we can see it
anywhere in the whole code even in this
function right here called fun too we
can see that we reference it here and
here and what we're gonna be able to see
it now this is an if statement which we
will talk more about later but we're
checking if the type of my global does
not equal undefined so it will not equal
undefined if it has been defined and the
program knows about the variable since
this is global scope it does not equal
undefined equals 10 the program knows
about the variable because this is in
global scope so since this function can
access the my global variable will run
what's in this if statement where we
just add to this output variable my
global and then we put with the value of
my global which is 10 now here's another
example where we're gonna see if if the
type of oops global equals undefined
well we're gonna set that here so it is
possible to set a variable without using
the VAR keyword so I'm gonna set this to
loop global equals 5 so you can see here
that there is no var keyword so normally
if you do use a var keyword since this
is within a function it will be scoped
to that function if we have the VAR
keyword here this will be scoped to
function so you would not be able to see
it in this function however since we
forgot to put the VAR keyword in this
example there's no VAR keyword it
becomes global automatically that means
you can access it anywhere else in the
program including here so if we put the
VAR keyword then oops global would equal
undefined and then we would never have
this line in the output however since we
did not put the VAR keyword
oops global equals 5 and this will be
added to the output
oops global and then the : 5 so when we
console dot log the output it's going to
say my global 10 oops Global 5 now
actually it's not going to say that
because this is in scrim ba' and in
scrim but it's it's more careful and
just enforces the fact that you have to
use a VAR keyword but if we were in our
browser it would not enforce the VAR
keyword and then it would actually show
my global 10 oops global 5 if this was a
little complicated don't worry about
that because a lot of these concepts
will be going over again later with
additional examples
variables which are declared within a
function as well as the function
parameters have local scope that means
they are only visible from within the
function let me show you what I mean if
I declare a variable right here my var
equals five so we've declared this
variable inside a function so this
variable my var is only visible inside
the function so it says console that
logged my var it should console that log
to five so we're gonna call the function
here and it's gonna console dialogue my
var but then the program is gonna run
this console dot log that's outside of
the function it's still going to try to
access my var and so let's see what
happens you can see in the console that
first there's a five because it console
dot log within the function then there's
an error because it tried to access my
var outside of the function so really we
just need to delete this where we try to
access the variable outside the function
and now there is no error
it is possible to have both local and
global variables with the same name when
you do this the local variable takes
precedence over the global variable let
me show you an example here we have a
function called my outfit that's going
to return outerwear that's this variable
up here this is a global variable
because it is declared outside of the
function so when we console that log the
output of the my outfit function or the
my outfit function is going to return
outerwear which is the war t-shirt so
let's check the console and you can see
yep
t-shirt is there however let's change
this up a bit so we have some space here
because I'm going to put var outerwear
equals sweater so now if I run this
program you can see in the console it's
going to say sweater instead of t-shirt
it's because this local variable
outerwear took precedence over the
global variable another thing
interesting thing about this if I do
console.log and I console that log that
outerwear variable we'll see that it's
still t-shirt so first you see in the
console says sweater and t-shirt so
first we console dot log this function
which is sweater
it returns sweater and then we console
that log the global variable which is
t-shirt
you can return a value from a function
with this return statement so we have
this function here and we are passing a
number into it the num and then it's
going to return whatever's after the
return keyword in this case num minus 7
so here we're going to consult out log
the function and it returns the result
of minus 7 is this 10 minus 7 which is 3
so it's going to cancel that log the
number 3 if we look in the console yep
it
console.log the number 3 because the
function returns 3 let's try creating
another one this function is going to be
called times 5 again we'll pass in a
number and it's just going to return
something it's going to return the num
times 5 and then just like before we can
test it using a console dot log times 5
and we'll pass in the number 5 here and
if I run this we'll see that it returns
number 25
functions can have return statements but
they don't have to in this case this
function adds three to the sum variable
which is a global variable because it's
defined before the function it does not
return anything so if you don't specify
a return value the return value is just
undefined now I'm going to create
another function that is similar this
one is going to copy called add five and
this time we'll just do some equals sum
plus five or we can shorten this to use
the plus equals two now that's going to
add 5 to sum also but it's not going to
return anything so if we log this out it
would be undefined
it's simple to assign a returned value
to a variable see right here we have the
function change and you pass the number
and it's going to return the result of
this mathematical expression so when we
call the function change and pass in the
10 the value that is returned from this
function is won't be stored in this
variable here we can do the same thing
down here first we initialize the
variable processed and process arrgh
it's going to return the result of this
mathematical expression so I can set
processed to equal what this function
returns so I can say processed argh and
then I'll just pass in the number 7 here
and now process
equals the result of this mathematical
expression
in computer science a queue is an
abstract data structure where items are
kept in order new items can be added to
the back of the queue and old items are
taken off from the front of the queue
we're going to simulate that right now
some of the functionality of a queue
using this next inline function so the
purpose of this is to show that in this
next inline function you can add an item
to the array that's passed in and then
it's going to return the first item on
the list for instance if we have this
array right here if we add them at an
item to this array it should come after
at the end so it should come after five
and then it should return the first item
on the list in this case it's one so you
see we have some console dot log set up
so it should show what the list looks
like the array looks like beforehand and
then show what it looks like afterwards
this JSON dot stringify is just a way to
change an array into a string that can
easily be printed out to the screen so
to do this we're just going to have to
do two things that we've learned about
already so the first thing is to add the
item onto the list so we see right here
next in line passed in the test array
and six so we're calling this function
next on line we're passing in this test
in this test
array here and the number six we want
the number six to be added to the end of
the array so we'll just do our push and
then I'll put in num just like that
well actually it's item so what we did
we took this array that was passed down
here which is in this case test array
and we pushed the item that was passed
in and in this case here it's im6 now we
want to return the first item on the
list we want to remove
and return this item so that when we
council that log here it should show the
number one so instead of returning item
I'm gonna return our shift
that's what shift does shift removes the
first item and returns that first item
so let's check this out okay you can see
before one two three four five then
we've popped off the one and after it's
two three four five six we did it
boolean czar another data type in
JavaScript there are only two values
true or false they're basically little
on-off switches where true is on and
false is off
they don't use quotation marks around
the the boolean C it just says return
false so this is a function here it
should be indented where it's just going
to return false when you call this
function it could also be true so we
could return true you can use true and
false in more places than just function
returns and we'll be talking more about
that later
an if statement is used to make
decisions in code the keyword if tells
JavaScript to execute the code in the
curly braces under certain conditions
defined in the parentheses so here is a
full if statement right here and there's
always parentheses after the keyword if
and here is the condition so if the
stuff inside this print inside these
parentheses evaluates to true then the
code within these curly braces will be
evaluated or run so in this case it's a
variable so if the is it true variable
is true it will return yes it's true now
if it's is not true then we'll get to
the second return statement no it's
false so this whole function here takes
in a variable and we check if that's
true or not so I'm gonna make another
example just like this we have another
function that hasn't been filled out yet
true or false and there's a variable S
pass in was that true so we'll say if
and then the parentheses was that true
but that's true we're going to return
something it will be a string just like
before and the string is yes that was
true if it's not true then we'll get
this second return statement in the
function and we'll return a different
string will return no that was false
false
let me just add some semicolons and then
I can run this and we'll see what
happens
Oh returnees we spelled correctly so let
me spell return correctly so before I
run this I'm going to edit console dot
log here so we can console to log the
answer so this is the function call here
true or false we're passing in true and
then we're going to log what
returned here yes that was true since we
passed and true this if same evaluates a
true and this code is run right here
there are many comparison operators in
JavaScript that will return a boolean of
true or false the most common is the
Equality operator and it's often used in
an if statement so here it just says if
Val so we have this whole if statement
right here if Val we're gonna see if if
Val equals 12 now to check if it equals
12 we're gonna have to use the double
equal sign that is the Equality operator
and we'll say if Val equals 12 the
reason why we can't just use a single
equal sign is that a single equal sign
is the assignment operator if we just
had a single equal sign that would mean
that we were setting the value of the
Val variable to equal 12 we're not
trying to set this to equal 12
we're trying to check if the value of
this variable equals 12 so we have to
use the double equal sign so now this
test equal function is going to test to
see if the number we pass in is equal to
12 I can do a console that law here
console dot log and then we can see what
appears in the console here not equal
because 10 does not equal 12
we learned about the Equality operator
which is the double equal sign there's
also the strict equality operator the
triple equal sign so here we're checking
if 3 equals 3 with the strict equality
operator so the difference is that the
Equality operator the double equal sign
attempts to convert both values being
compared to a common type while the
strict equality operator does not do the
type conversion so this is going to
evaluate to true the 3 equals equals
equals 3 but the 3 equals equals equals
3 with the string on this side is going
to evaluate to false both of these would
be true if we were using the double
equal sign because the string would be
converted to a number and they would be
equal to true but with the triple equal
sign it does not get converted to a
number so it would be evaluate to false
the second one with the 3 equal signs so
here we're just going to use it right in
this if statement and who equals equals
equals 7 so now we can pass in the
number 7 and it's going to evaluate to
true but if we pass in a string 7 it
will evaluate to false
we will do one more review with the
Equality operator and the strict
equality operator so if I run this here
we'll see in the the console says equal
because it's checking if the number 10
and the string 10 are equal so if a
equals B the number 10 equals a strict
number 10 returned equal since we're
using the Equality operator with with
two equal signs it performs a type
conversion and it converts the string
into a number but if we use the strict
equality operator with three equal signs
I'll run that again and you'll see not
equal in the console because now it's
not converting the types and it's just
checking if a number is equal to a
string which is not so we get not equal
now I will show you the inequality
operator which is basically the opposite
of the Equality operator so I'm gonna do
the inequality operator with an
exclamation point in an equal sign in
this case I'm going to see if the value
is not equal to 99 and again just like
the Equality operator this does type
conversion so let's just run this
program and we'll see it is not equal
because 10 we pass them 10 into the
function here and 10 is not equal to 99
so we get not equal
the strict inequality operator is
basically the opposite of the strict
equality operator and works like this so
it says if Val I'm going to do if Val
does not equal 17 so this is the strict
inequality operator instead of one equal
sign we have two equal signs and that
means it's going to check if this is not
true but it's not going to convert types
so for instance if we are checking if
the number three does not equal the
string three that would be true so in
this example we're just checking if ten
does not equal 17 if we run this we will
see it's not equal
we can also use the greater than
operator so in this function we're
checking if a value is over 100 so I'm
going to put greater than 100 and then
here we're checking if a value is over
10 so I'll put greater than 10 so here
we call the function we pass in 10 and
if I run that function you'll see 10 or
under because we're not over 100 we're
not over 10 or 10 or under because we
passed in 10
we can also use the greater than or
equal to operator so we'll finish this
function by using greater than or equal
to that's just a greater than sign in an
equal sign and we'll put 20 down here
just greater than or equal to 10 if I
run that we should see 10 or over
because we're passing in 10 and it's
greater than or equal to 10
now I'll show you an example of the less
than operator with this function we're
going to check if the value is less than
25 and then here we're checking if a
value is less than 55 so here's a trick
I use to remember which symbol is less
than 1 which symbol is more than if you
see the less than symbol looks kind of
like the letter L which is the first
letter in less than and then the more
than symbol is just the opposite
and we also have the less than or equal
to operator we can use in JavaScript so
here we're going to check if it's less
than or equal to 12 so we just put the
less than operator 12 Oh evil less than
or equal that's an important part here
it's the less than or equal to 24 to
make this statement true and if we run
we see smaller than or equal to 12
number 10 we passed in
sometimes you want to check if two
things are true at the same time for
instance you may want to check if this
value is less than or equal to 50 and
you also want to check if the value is
more than or equal to 25 so we here we
have a nested if statement so it's going
to check if it's less than equal to 50
and if it's more than equal to 25 then
it's going to return yes but there's an
easier way to do this so what I'm going
to do is copy this where it says value
is more than or equal to 25 I'm going to
delete this nested if statement so we
don't need that if statement and I'm
going to use the and operator so we have
less than or equal to 50 and if I put
two ampersands like this that means and
now I'm going to put value is more than
or equal to 25 so this says if value is
less than or equal to 50 and the value
is also more than or equal to 25 then
we're going to return yes so both this
statement and this statement have to be
true to get into inside this if
statement here
in this code here we're checking if the
value is not between 10 and 20 so if the
value is less than 10 we return outside
and if the value is more than 20 we
return outside there is an easier way to
do this with the logical or operator so
I'm just going to delete this whole if
statement here and then I can add an or
statement which is just 2 pipes so I'm
going to put Val is less than or it more
than 20 here so now we're checking if
the value is less than 10 or if the
value is more than 20 either way we're
going to return outside and if that's
not true we'll return inside
when an if steam is true normally the
block of code right after the if
statement will be evaluated and if it's
not true nothing happens but with an
else statement an alternate block of
code can be executed when it's not true
so this is a perfect use case if value
is more than five the result is bigger
than five if there is if the value is
less than or equal to five the result is
five or smaller we can do this with an
else statement so I'm just going to type
in else here and then we can just delete
this whole if statement just like that
and now we have if the value is less
than five the results will be bigger
than five else if it's which is if it's
not more than five we'll return five or
smaller
if you have multiple conditions that
need to be addressed you can use else if
statements it's a way of chaining if
statements together in this example we
have three conditions if value is more
than 10 we're gonna return greater than
10 if it's less than 5 returns smaller
than 5 or else we're gonna return 5 and
up so this is a perfect use case for an
else if statement so this is how we do
it well do else and then just we're
going to add the if statement at the end
of the else I'm just gonna delete all
this stuff so else if value is less than
5 and then we're gonna have one final
else statement else and I'm going to put
this statement here this final return
just gonna cut that and then paste it
right in there so now we've instead of
using multiple if statements we have the
if and only the else if and then we have
the else
when you're using else if statements
order is very important let's look at
this example here in this function first
we check if the value is less than 10
and return less than 10 then else if we
check if the value is less than 5 and
return less than 5 well if we look at
this example when we pass in the number
7 if I run this you'll see it's going to
say less than 10 which is what we want
however if we put 3 it's still just
gonna say less than 10 really we want
this to say less than 5 because it is
actually less than 5
however the this is in the wrong order
so what we need to do is change the
order so this should be 5 this should be
5 and this should be 10 and this should
be 10 so once the first condition is met
it doesn't even check for the rest of
the conditions so that's why it's
important to think about the order so if
we run this now yep less than 5 that's
what we want
you can also chain if and else if
statements so I'm going to complete the
following challenge here right chained
if / else if statements to fulfill the
following conditions so we have these
conditions where if the number is less
than five we're gonna return tiny if
it's less than ten returns small and so
on so what I'm gonna do is actually just
copy this right here because this is
written as part of it's written exactly
how we want to be written I'll just
paste it here and I'm going to just add
the if and else statement so it's gonna
be if and then we put this in
parentheses because the condition is
always in parentheses if number is less
than five then we're going to use the
curly braces and we're going to return
tiny so I'll just move that up here I'll
cut it and paste it now we're going to
use an else if statement and I got the
curly braces
first of all also I need to put the
condition in these parentheses I'm just
going to cut this number is less than
ten put right here and we're gonna
return this small so I'll put that in
the curly braces here and then we have
another else if statement else if and
the condition just like before number is
less than fifteen but that in there we
get we always need the curly braces to
show what's going to happen in the if
statement so I'm just cutting and
pasting the text again we have an else
if and then we have this year and we
have return large another actually the
final thing is just going to be else we
don't even need an else if at the
statement at the end we're not we don't
even need to put the condition because
if it's more than equal to twenty that's
going to be everything else so I'm just
going to cut this we don't need any of
this stuff here and we're just going to
return
and large so with this one test here for
test seven we can actually cancel that
log that console dot log and see what
returns for seven we can try a few
different things
ooh we have an ear here oh forget to it
but this parenthesis wrong way let's try
that again
small but if this is 20 it should be
huge and if it's 19 which would be less
than 20 we should see you large yep that
worth
in the game of golf each hole has a par
which means the average number of
strokes you're supposed to use to get
the ball into the hole so depending on
how far above or below par your strokes
are there's a different nickname so here
are some of the nicknames hole-in-one
Eagle birdie par and we're gonna write a
function where you pass in the par and
you also pass on the stroke so you can
see up here par and strokes and it's
going to return the nickname so that's
what we're going to write you can see
this table here shows what we have to do
if the strokes are 1 then you get a
hole-in-one
if the stroke is less than or equal to
par minus 2 you get an eagle and so on
and we also have this array that's gonna
make it easier because we can you just
use things from this array instead of
typing out the words so we're going to
start with an if statement if and then
we have to put the condition if strokes
equals equals that's the Equality
operator we don't want to use a single
equal sign because that would be the
assignment operator if it equals 1 then
we can return and we can see down here
we're gonna return hole-in-one but we
can just use it from this names array so
it's going to be named and this is the
meet index 0 of the array so we'll do
names and then 0 and then we can do an
else if else if and then we can put the
condition strokes expel strokes right
spokes and then we can just actually
copy this right from here less than or
equal to power minus 2 and then we are
going to return name and this will be
the index 1 which is an eagle at this
point I can do some copying and pasting
I'm going to copy this whole thing's a
lot of this rest of this will be else if
so else if strokes is this time is going
to be equal
to par - one and we're going to return
this many birdie which is array index -
and I'm going to continue just like this
so this time it's if strokes equal par
we're going to return name index 3 C 0 1
2 3 is going to be the word par up here
they'll just keep just like this now
it's going to be R plus 1 and we'll
change this to 4 now it's going to be
par plus 2 and we'll change this to 5
which is gonna be the double bogey
and finally if strokes is change this to
more than or equal to car plus 3 that
means you did very poorly so you should
just go home so it's going to be named
index 6 and we don't need this anymore
so now we're gonna do some tests here
I'm gonna do a console console dot log
and we're going to pass in the function
that we're calling so in this case the
par is 5 and the strokes are 4 so that
should return birdie let's see what
happens
no ok that's not what I expected it's
because this should be names spelled
this wrong and that's why sometimes
better to check before you go through
the whole thing you can test things as
you go but let's do that again
yep birdie and if I type in 2 here eagle
if I
type and eat it's probably that tell us
to go home go home yep we just completed
this challenge
instead of using chained else if
statements you can use a switch
statement a switch statement test of
value and can have many case statements
which define various possible values so
let me show you how that works here
we're going to write a switch statement
which tests Val and sets the answer to
the following conditions if we pass in
one the answer should be alpha if we
pass on to the answer should be beta and
so on so let me show you how that works
we'll just type in the word switch
that's a key word here and we're testing
the valve that's passed into this
function so it starts off kind of like
an if statement and right now so we're
gonna compare the Val to the different
cases that we have so we'll have case
and the first number is going to be one
so here we're saying if the case of Val
is 1 if Val equals 1 and it's using the
strict equality operator so it's like
that equals equals equals it's going to
make sure that the type of the variable
are the same so a string 1 and a number
1 will not be equal but if the case is 1
then we're going to set answer to equal
alpha we'll just use the like this alpha
and then we are going to break break
means that we're at the end of that case
statement and once you break it it just
goes to the end of the switch statement
it doesn't evaluate anything else in the
switch statement so we're also going to
have case two and one thing I forgot
that we're gonna is going to end in that
so it's easier to see the different
cases and case 2 the answer is going to
set equal to beta and then we always
need the break statement if you don't
have a break statement it will just run
through to the next case statement
automatically so if the case was one and
you did not have a break here first who
would set the and
alpha and then it would set the answer
to beta it would just skip over right to
the next case Thema but since the break
is here it's going to go out of the
switch damn it completely so it would go
start writing the code after this last
curly bracket so now we're going to case
three we'll just do some copying and
pasting here and we're gonna have four
cases I'll just do the rest of the cop
the pasting here so we'll have three and
four alpha beta and then we have gamma
and Delta and we know that the switch
statement is over because we have this
final curly bracket and then we're just
going to return answer so let's do some
tests to really test this we're going to
have to add a console dot log here to
log what it's going to be and I'll run
this alpha good now two should be beta 3
should be gamma good and we'll just
assume for is correct
so we're done
now I'll talk to you about the default
option in a switch statement the default
option is kind of like else in an
if-else statement so here's a switch
statement that's very similar to the one
we already saw and it's inside this
function where we pass in a value into
the function and we're going to check if
the value equals a if it equals a the
answer is gonna be set to Apple B
intercept the birds see cat so in this
example we can see that we passed in
here we pass in a and it returned Apple
because that was one of the options but
what if we pass in something else if I
pass in the number two here it's going
to return an empty string that's because
the answer is set to an empty string and
we never override the answer here so it
just returns that empty string what if
we want to return something anytime a B
or C is not passed through so for
anything else that's passed into the
function we're gonna do default this is
like the else statement so the default
we're gonna do answer equals it's off
again we're gonna have the break so now
whenever we pass in something that's not
a B or C it's gonna return stuff so we
can pass in five it's gonna rain return
stuff but if I go back the pass again
see one of the things they have a case
for it'll return cat and that's the
switch statement
sometimes you want a switch statement
where multiple inputs give the same
output well that's easy enough by
omitting the break statement let me show
you how that works so let's get a switch
statement here and we're gonna have Val
that's what's passed into the function
and in this case when you want the case
of one two and three all to return the
answer of lo so I can do it like this
case one and I can go straight into case
two and then I can go straight into case
three and since I don't have any break
statement between these cases it will
just keep going to the next one
automatically and now I'm gonna say that
the answer is must be set to equal low
and here is where I put the break
statement okay now we're gonna do the
same thing with cases four through six
and actually I'm just going to do some
copying and pasting I'm gonna copy all
this and now we're going to paste that's
four five six we're gonna do the same
thing with seven eight nine so I'm gonna
do copy and paste again and then I'm
just going to update the code so this is
gonna be four five six we'll have seven
eight nine and we're gonna have mid and
high so if the case is one two or three
like for instance if it's one it's gonna
pass through two and three to get low
and then it's gonna break out if it's
four five or six it's gonna pass through
to get to mid and then it's gonna break
out seven eight nine it's gonna pass
through to high and break out so let's
test this out and see since we're
passing in the number one here it's
going to be low but if we pass in five
we should get mid and if it's seven
eight or nine
we should get high
sometimes a switch statement can be
easier to write and easier to understand
then a chain of if-else statements so
we're going to change this chain of else
if statements to become a switch
statement so let's do that right now
so I'm gonna start with the switch
keyword and we're going to be evaluating
the value with open curly braket and we
want to make sure to have an end curly
bracket end so for a case Bob we're
gonna set the answer to Marlee and then
we need to have a break in here for case
42 we're gonna set the answer to the
answer or case one whole set the answer
to there is no number one oh we need a
break up here for case 99 the answer is
miss by this much and then we need a
break now we have for case seven well
seven eight nine and break and now we
just changed that chain of else if
statements into a switch statement
here's a little trick when you want a
function to return a boolean a true or
false value you can see in this function
we're checking if a is less than B and
if so we return true else we return
false you may remember from before that
all comparison operators return a
boolean true or false value so instead
of using this if statement here we can
just do that we can actually delete all
of this and just return the result of
this return we're just returning the
result of a is less than B so this is
going to be true or false and we can
just skip that whole if statement logic
and just return this so if we consul
don't log this out console.log we should
be able to see if 10 is less than 15 it
is less than 15 it's true but if we put
a 20 here and it's false
we've already seen a few examples of
this but you can return early from a
function with the return statement so if
you see this this function right here we
return at the very end of the function
and so it leaves a function and returns
this value from the function but you can
leave the function anytime with a return
statement so we're going to modify this
function so that if a or b are less than
zero the function will immediately exit
with a value of undefined so let's do
that we're gonna set an if statement if
a is less than zero or that's two pipes
B is less than zero then we're going to
return an undefined so we can do a test
here console.log eight but what if this
is a negative number it's going to
return undefined Skrim beheads a little
quirk here where it just shows null but
in a browser will show undefined
we are going to create a blackjack card
counting function so how how card
counting works at least how this
function is gonna work is that when you
see a low card that count goes up and
when you see a high card that count goes
down and if it's a middle value card the
count stays the same and then when the
count is positive the player should bet
high and when the count is zero or
negative the player should bet low so we
are going to use a switch statement to
figure out what card has been passed in
and what to do about it you can see that
the function looks like this see see and
we pass in a card and depending on what
the card is it's going to increase this
global count variable or it's going to
decrease it or it's going to stay the
same and then we are going to return two
things we're not gonna return changeme
we are going to return the current count
value and whether the player should hold
or bet so every time you call the CC
function it's going to change this count
value and return the total count so
let's see how this is going to work we
are going to use the switch statement
like I said and we're going to check the
card value that was passed in so if the
case is 2 3 4 5 6 we are going to
increment the count variable so we're
going to do like this case 2 I'm going
to do some copying and pasting if the
case is 2 3 4 5 6
well it just had to actually change
these values 3 4 5 6 now there are many
ways to write any program this could be
done with if statements and else
statements it could be even done with
other other ways that we haven't even
talked about yet as long as the program
works in this case that's all that
matters so if you find a different way
to write this program
that's great so if the case is two three
four five or six we are going to take
the account value and if we just do plus
plus that increments it by one and then
we're going to break now if the case is
seven eight nine so let's pay some three
of these blue seven eight nine actually
we're going to do nothing the account is
not going to change at all so we don't
even need case seven or eight nine so
instead of doing seven eight nine we
just need to check in the case that
something is actually going to happen so
we are going to decrement the count
variable if we have ten Jack queen king
or ace so that's what we're gonna change
this to ten Jack queen king or bass in
this case we're going to decrement the
count so you can do count - - so that's
the same as count equals count minus one
and then we will break now we've taken
care of the count and up game account
now we have to take care of what we're
going to return we are going to return
the count and we're also going to return
whether we are going to hold or bet so
we're going to actually return a
variable but first we're going to space
there's a space between the number and
then we're going to return the hold
variable now this is a variable we
haven't created yet normally this would
be the perfect time to use the ternary
operator but we haven't learned that yet
and what we're not going to learn that
for a few more lessons so I won't use
that now we are going to set what that
hold that value is first we'll create
the hold variable variable hold back and
we'll set it to
hold however if count is more than zero
then we can set hold that to equal that
so now this should work let's test it
out and see if we've made any mistakes
yet hold that is not defined well we
have it right here
hold Oh we spelled that wrong so instead
of halt bet that should we hold that
okay in this case we're going to bet
because we had a bunch of positive
numbers and then negative numbers but if
we change this to K I change this to 10
what do what happens now we're gonna
hold okay it worked
objects objects are similar to arrays
except that instead of using indexes to
access data you use properties so here's
an object called our dog objects are
going to be defined with these curly
braces before at the beginning of the
end and these are the properties now the
properties are everything before the
colons so we have name that's a property
legs the property and then the values
are the things after the colons here so
the name is camper the legs four tails
there's like one tail on this dog and
friends are everything now you can see
that with the properties can be strings
they can be numbers they can be arrays
they can be any data type in JavaScript
so now we are going to create our own
dog so this is going to have a name
personally I like the name Quincy so
we'll use that for our dog's name also
we're going to have legs unfortunately
our dog has had an accident he only has
three legs but to make up for the only
having three legs he does have two tails
and four friends another unfortunate
thing it's an empty array he has no
friends okay we've now created our own
object
there are two main ways to access a
property on an object the first I will
talk about is dot notation so we have
this test object and we have hat shirt
and shoes and we want to find out the
value of these properties so right here
the hat value we're gonna set a test
object now here's where we use the dot
notation we just put a dot or a period
and then I put the name of the property
about hat and then for the shirt value I
will do dot shirt so see this word right
here is just the word here so the value
of hat value test object that hat is now
gonna be ball cap and the value of the
shirt value is going to be jersey
besides using dot notation you can also
use bracket notation to access a
property and an object you can use
bracket notation anytime but it is
required if the name has a space in it
you can see in this object we have three
properties and each of them have a space
so to get the value of these properties
we're going to have to use bracket
notation so the entre value we're going
to test object that's the name of the
object and then we're gonna put brackets
kind of like an array index so you need
the opening and closing brackets and
inside we will put the name of the
property so I'll do a an entree and then
we can do it again down here for the
drink value and I'll I'll use a single
quote this happens have a double quote
to show that each of those will work the
drink and then we need the closing
brackets here so now Andre value is set
equal hamburger and drink value is set
to equal water
bracket notation can also be used to
look up object properties using
variables so here we have this test
object we have these different numbers
associated with these names here and we
are going to set this variable to be one
of the numbers so I'll set this to be 16
so now we can in this test object 16 is
Montana and we can look that up using
the variable name instead of the numbers
so instead of putting 16 I'm going to
put player number in here and now player
is set to the word the string Montana
and we use this variable to look up the
object property
we can use dot notation to update object
properties here you can see an object
called our dog it has a named legs tails
friends and the name is camper however
here we use dot notation our dog name
and use the assignment operator the
equal sign to set the name to happy
camper so if we did console dot log on
our dog name it would no longer be
camper it would be happy camper well we
have another dog here with a name of
coder but we want to change the name to
happy coder so that's what I'll do right
here so my dog dot name equals happy
coder so just like above we use dot
notation to set the object property to a
new value
you can add new properties to an object
using dot notation or bracket notation
so here's an example right here we have
this object our dog and there's four
properties here but down here we're
adding a new property our dog bark
equals bow-wow so it had four properties
but now it has five properties as the
property bark as well now down here
we'll add a property to the my dog
object so we can do my dog and then here
I'm going to use bracket notation set
dot notation bark I'm going to set that
to equal booth and because he's yelling
it will have an exclamation point and
that's how you add properties to objects
it's simple to delete a property from an
object our dog object has all these
properties and with the delete keyword
delete our dog bark so now this property
here the bark has been deleted and is no
longer in the object after we have
deleted it so we can do the same thing
down here and this time we will delete
the Hills property my dog that kills so
now the my dog object no longer has a
tails property
objects can be thought of as a key value
storage like a dictionary you can use an
object to look up values so in this case
we have a switch statement that returns
certain values so when you pass an alpha
to the function it returns Adams if you
pass in Bravo it returns Boston we can
replace this switch statement with an
object and use the object for lookups
instead of the switch statement let me
show you how that's done I'm going to
create var lookup this is going to be an
object here and the object is going to
have a bunch of key value pairs so we
have alpha and that's going to be Adams
and then we have Bravo and the value for
Bravo is going to be Boston and that's
it so we can now delete this whole
switch statement and now we can say
result equals lookup in bracket notation
we put the value that was passed in and
I forgot one thing which was the equal
sign here because lookup equals this
object and let's do a test so let me put
console dot log so we can actually see
what happens here so if we do charlie
we're gonna get Chicago if we do Foxtrot
the result will be Frank so it works
you can check if an object has a
property with the has owned property
method let me show you how to use this
method and finish making this function
where we check if an object has a
specific property if it doesn't have the
property will return not found so let me
show you how that's going to work we'll
do my abs that's the object up above
dock has owned dropped 40 and then we
pass in the property we're gonna check
which is check crop this is either gonna
come back as true or false if it has the
property so let's make this into an if
statement if my my object has own
property check crop but if that's true
we're going to return my ABS and then
use bracket notation check crop so go
we're going to return the value of that
property else we're going to return not
found so let's pick up this other return
statement and I'll do a test so when we
pass in gift here we returned pony but
let's say we passed in hello you load
that not found okay it works
a JavaScript object is a way to store
flexible data so you can store strings
numbers and arrays and even other
objects so in this example we have an
array called MyMusic we can see it's an
array because we have the open break and
closed bracket but inside the array are
objects so this is one of the objects
and inside the objects are all these key
value pairs with the strings and the
numbers and so on so I'm going to add
another object so since this is array
after each element in an array you have
a comma so I'm gonna add a comma here
and then I'm going to add my next record
right below this comment here and we are
going to have just like well above we're
gonna have an artist the artist is going
to be Bo Carnes and then we have a title
the title will be a serial man the
release year will be 2003 and for
formats this is going to be an array
it's just like above so we can have any
format I'm gonna put YouTube video and
now we've created a second object in our
in our my music array and each objects
hold data in a property which is the key
value format this is very similar to
JSON which we will talk more about later
here we have an object with other
objects nested inside that so in order
to access sub properties of an object
you can chain together the dot or
bracket notation so I'm trying to get
the glove box contents so I'm going to
take away this undefined here and I'll
do my storage dot car dot inside and
then now the next thing it's it with a
car inside the last thing is glove box
because there's a space here we have to
use bracket a shin so I'm gonna use
bracket notation on the end here and say
glove box and now if we run this C we
are going to console that lock so let's
see if we get the contents here yep Maps
it worked
arrey bracket notation
to access nested arrays you can see we
have this array here and inside this
array are two objects the first elm and
the array is this object the second elm
and array is this object and then inside
the object we have a key value pair the
key is less and the value is another
array here so we can combine dot
notation and bracket notation to access
the second tree that's what we're trying
to do here so let's do that first we
need to do my plants and the trees are
the second element in the my plant array
which is index one now we need to get
though the list so the list of trees
here so I'm going to do dot lists and
since that list is an array I can use
the bracket notation to get the the
second list element which again is array
index one so if we run this it's going
to console that log and we see pine
that's the second tree here
this is a coding challenge we're gonna
do we're giving given this object here
which is a record collection each record
has an ID and then it also has different
pieces of information about the record
they don't all have the same information
but see we have art album artist tracks
album artist tracks this just says
artist tracks and this just has album
here and we are supposed to create this
update records function where we can
pass in the ID the property and the
value and it's going to update our
record collection with the property of
the value so for instance if we pass in
the ID
2468 and we put the property artists and
if we set a different value like Quincy
or something like that then we should
update this whole object so now it says
Quincy instead of prints and we should
return the full collection so it's going
to update the collection and then return
the collection if we have an empty
string for the value it should just
completely delete that property also if
we have the property of tracks and then
we have a value instead of updating the
whole tracks here with what we put in
it's just going to add the track to the
end of this array so if you look right
here it says the comment says keep a
copy of the collection for tests this
JSON dot parse and json dot stringify
and then collection this is just a fancy
way in JavaScript to make a copy of the
object remember in our function we are
going to be changing the collection
object but we want to have a copy of the
original object before anything was
changed so that's what that's for so
let's go ahead and do that so we're just
updating this function here this update
records function okay so let's get to
this so we'll do if value
equals equals equals blank because the
first condition we are going to test for
is if we need to delete the property
remember if the value is at the blank we
delete that property so if the value is
blank we are going to delete election
and then we have to use bracket n ID and
then try the collection ID crop that's
the collection here if we pass in the ID
1248 it will go to there the property if
we passed an album for the property will
go to here and then we'll just delete
that whole thing if our values in the
empty string okay the next condition we
have to look for is if the property is
tracks because for most properties we're
just going to override that property
with the value passed into the function
but if the property is tracks we are
going to push on to the end of the array
so let's do an else if else if prop
equals equals equals tracks then we just
have to push on to the end of the array
so there's also another condition here
which is if the tracks property is empty
if the tracks property is empty we need
to create it here's a fancy way to do
that collection ID props so if prop
equals tracks we are going to set the
tracks because we're prop is going to
equal track we're going to set the
tracks to equal it's going to either
equal itself if it exists or if it
doesn't exist we're going to create it
I'll show you how collection ID huh it's
gonna equal itself or that's the or
operator it's going to equal an empty
array so if this already exists we're
gonna set to equal itself but if itself
doesn't exist
we'll just set it to equal and empty
array so that's just a way to create
that property if it doesn't already
exist so now that we know it exists we
can just push the value to the end of
the array
collection ID prop and we'll just do the
dot push and then put in the parentheses
the value so we're able to push the
value that was passed into this function
onto the end of the array okay there's
only one last condition which is the
just kind of the default condition else
so if the values in blank and the
property isn't tracks then we just push
the value onto the property then we just
set the property to equal the value just
like this collection ID prop equals
value okay let's test this out so we
already have this example down here but
to see if it actually worked we're going
to do a consult log so we can see the
output there and if I run that I'll let
me open up the console so I can really
see it so let's see what we changed go
to 5 4 3 9 and we set the artist which
didn't previously exist to ABBA
so let's look down here in the console 5
4 3 9 and the artist is ABBA
let's see what happens when we add a
track so we'll do one more example here
I'll just put right above here 8 records
and I'm going to pass in something I'll
pass in let's see the ID 2 4 6 8 and
we'll pass in the key which is going to
be tracks and then for the value
we'll put test
so let's see what happens here if we run
that it's gonna update the record here
and that's gonna update the record again
but we don't care about that one we may
like hear that it's gonna console that
log what the final value is so if we
look at 2 4 6 8 here 2 4 6 8 let's see
the tracks we at 1999 little red
Corvette and test so it's working great
loop's allow you to run the same code
multiple times I'm going to talk to you
about a while loop that runs while a
specified condition is true and stops
once it's no longer true so we are going
to push the digit 0 through 4 on to this
array here's how it's going to work
while it's a while loop while I is less
than 5 and we're gonna do something
while that's true first with a set where
I I starts off at at so var I equals 0
so while I is less m 5 will do my array
push hi just push it onto the array and
to make sure this loop eventually ends
I'll have to do I plus plus which
increments I so then I will test this
out by doing console dot log and I'm
gonna console that log to my array so
let's see if this works I'll run this
and check the console 0 1 2 3 4 the
while loop worked every time we went
through this five different times and
pushed 0 1 2 3 & 4 onto the loop
a for-loop is the most common type of
loop in JavaScript so here is an example
of a for loop you start with the keyword
for and then we have these parentheses
with three different items and they're
separated by semicolons the first thing
is the initialization then we have the
condition then we have the final
expression so the initialization happens
before any of the code inside the loop
runs so we will start by initializing I
to equal 0 so this is what most for
loops start with is you have a variable
that you're going to initialize for the
for loop then the next thing is the
condition so once this evaluates to
false we break out of the loop so while
I is less than 5 we'll continue to run
through the loop over and over until
this is false and we break out of the
loop the final thing is what we do at
the end of each iteration at the end of
each iteration we will increment I by 1
in this example we are filling our array
with the numbers 0 through 4 I'm going
to do another example where we fill an
array with the numbers 1 through 5 so
we'll start with for now we're gonna
initialize I to equal 1 we're starting
with 1 instead of 0 this time and we're
gonna do I is less than 6 so while I is
less than 6 or until I is more than 6 we
are going to run all the code in this
loop and at the end of each iteration we
are going to increment I now I can just
do what we have before my array dot push
hi so the final thing we will do is test
this I will do console dot log and put
my array inside here and I'll just load
this and see what we see in the console
1 2 3 4 5 it worked we iterated 5
different times and each time we pushed
a new digit on to the array and at the
end of each iteration we incremented I
so
it pushed a larger number onto the array
loop's don't just have to increment one
at a time
look at this for loop here we have our
initialization where we initialize I to
0 and then we are going to run the loop
until I is less than 10 and finally
there are increment instead of
incrementing I by 1 we're incrementing I
by 2 so now this is going to push all
the even numbers onto the array we have
console dot log so let's log it out and
see what it looks like 0 2 4 6 8 I'm
going to write another loop right now
that creates an array of odd numbers so
let's do that for VAR i equals 1 we'll
start at 1 while I is less than 10
I can use 10 again I'm gonna do I plus
equal to so we're still going to skip
count by twos but since we're starting
at 1 instead of 0 this should give us
the odd numbers so let's see what's
gonna be inside our loop my array dot
plush and I'll just put I there so let's
log this out and see if we did it right
console dot log my array and I'll run
that 1 3 5 7 9 it worked
a for-loop can also be used to count
backwards so if we see this for loop
here we're initializing I to 10 we're
starting at 10 and we're going back to 0
so we're gonna iterate through this loop
while I is more than 0 we're going to
keep iterating and at the end of each
iteration we're gonna decrement I
instead of increment it we're gonna go
down by 2 i minus equals 2 means i
equals I minus 2 so we're gonna continue
pushing the lower and lower numbers onto
the array until I is less than 0 so
let's log this out and see what our
array becomes you can see 10 8 6 4 2
well I'm gonna write another one where
we're gonna push the odd numbers from 9
through 1 to my I took the my array so
another for loop and I'm going to do VAR
I equals 9 because we want to start at 9
now we'll still do I is more than 0 so
while I is more than 0 we're gonna keep
going through this array and we'll do I
and we just everything else is really
the same - equals 2 and this is gonna
get all the odd numbers onto the array
so we just have to do my array dot push
and then push on the I there and I'll
just console that log so we can see what
it ended up as my array and I'll run the
code 9 7 5 3 1 we did it
it is common in JavaScript to iterate
through the contents of an array so look
at this example we have this array here
before we were are always adding items
to the array but this time the array
already exists right here our array 9 10
11 12 so we are going to start at 0 but
now instead of going to a specific
number of iterations we are going to the
our array dot length so the length is 4
here but if we added elements to this
array that means this loop would just go
even longer until we went through every
element of that array and then at the
end we're going to increment I by 1 at
the end of each iteration so look what
we're doing inside the array we're doing
our total that starts out at 0 up here
and we're doing plus equals that means
we're going to do our total equals our
total plus something else so we're gonna
keep adding to the total whatever is in
the array at that index so our array I
so it starts at 0 and then it goes 1 2 3
until it gets to 4 which is the length
of the array and it doesn't even run the
iteration at 4 and there is no index 4
on the array remember it's 0 1 2 3 so
this is just going to add up all those
numbers if we run this we can see it
adds up to 42 I'm gonna write another
for loop down here that's going to add
up all the numbers in this array here so
we'll do for our I equals 0 and then we
do I is less than my array dot length
and I plus plus so just like before for
each element in my array we're gonna do
a my we're going to do a total
plus equals my array index I so we have
to initialize the total variable right
up here so the VAR total equals zero and
then at the end we can just we'll just
console dot log that out to see what the
total is so if I just run this we can
see that the total this time is 20
if you have a multi-dimensional or
nested array you can use nested
for-loops to access all the array
elements so for instance we have this
multiply off function it's defined up
here but we're calling it here and we're
passing in this multi-dimensional array
which is basically an array with arrays
inside the array so inside the first
array there are three elements 1 2 3 and
you can see each of those elements are
an array with their own set of elements
so we are going to use nested for-loops
within this multiply all function to
multiply every number in these nested
arrays here so let's get started we're
going to start with a for loop and it's
going to look just like the other four
loops that we started I equals 0 we're
going to initialize I to 0 and then
we're gonna say while I is less than our
length and then we're just going to
increment I at the end of each iteration
now are that linked that's going to
start off as 3 because we're passing in
this array and the first level of the
array there's just 1 2 3 elements so
that's gonna be 3 but now we're gonna go
inside this for loop and create another
for loop so we're gonna do VAR J equals
0 normally its standard practice to call
the variable that we're incrementing I
but we already have an eye within this
scope so we need to create another name
and it's pretty standard to call the
next variable J because J is after I so
now we're gonna do J while J is less
than now this is where it gets a little
tricky we're gonna do while a is less
than our index I dot length also we're
gonna increment J here so this is going
to change so first the first iteration
of this outer for loop we're looking at
the length of this array then we're
linking looking at the length of this
array then we're looking at the length
of this array the index is going to be
different every time so we're going to
be going to each different
inside the nested array so at this point
we just have to multiply all the numbers
together so we already have the product
that we've defined above so we're gonna
do product x equals which is just gonna
multiply everything together and we're
going to do our eye Hey so the eye
references the outer array and the J
references the inner array within the
what we're passing in and now we're done
so let's we have the console dot log
here so let's run this and see what
happens and 5040
next I'm going to talk about do-while
loops now we already talked about while
loops and I'm gonna review this while
loop and then I will tell you how a
do-while loop is different than a while
loop so this while loop first checks the
condition before it runs any code within
the loop a do while loop will always run
at least one time and then it will check
the condition so here we have this empty
array we have I equals 10 so while I is
less than 5 well I is not less than 5 so
it's not gonna do anything let's see
what happens so we see it logged out 10
and then an empty array because I
started as 10 and my array started as
this empty erase you were logging the I
and my array with a do-while loop it's
different so what I'm going to do is cut
this line up here and put it at the end
and then at the beginning I'm gonna put
the keyword do in a do-while loop this
is always run at least once before it
checks the condition so first it's going
to do these things and then it's going
to check the condition in this case it's
going to find out the condition as false
and it's going to break out of the loop
let's see what happens here
see now I is 11 and the array has the 10
added to it
this is a coding challenge we have this
array of objects in our context lists
and you'll see each object is one of our
contacts with the first name a last name
a number and likes so these are key
value pairs here so what we want to do
is create this lookup profile function
where we pass in a name this is a first
name and the property and it's going to
return the value of that property for
instance if we pass in the name christen
here and we pass in the property of a
number it should return unknown if we
pass in the first name of Sherlock up
here and we return the property and we
pass in the property of likes it should
return the array intriguing cases and
violin if the name that's passed in does
not correspond to any context then our
functions to return no such contact and
if there's no property it should return
no such property so let's go to this
function here and start creating it so
the first thing we're going to have to
do is iterate through each element in
the contacts list so let's make a for
loop so for bar VAR I equals 0
while I is less than contacts length and
at the end of each iteration we'll do i
+ + to increment that so for each of
these contacts the first thing we're
going to check is if the name is a name
in this list so if contacts I
first name equals equals equals the name
that was passed in so we're checking
each eye to see if was the name that was
passed in and if so we're going to do
something now if now we're gonna do
something else so let's do that now
remember if the name that was passed in
is not in the array we're going to
return no such contact however if it is
in the array we're gonna do something
else if the name is in the context list
we're going to return the value of the
property that was passed in so return
contacts
I dropped so this will return the value
of that property that was passed in
however there is another case which is
if the property does not exist we return
no such property so a fancy way in
JavaScript of saying use this value if
it exists but otherwise use a different
value is to use the or operator
so we'll say return contact I prop or if
it doesn't exist we're gonna return no
such property and just so you know there
would be a way to do this without using
this or operator as long as that your
code passes the requirements that's all
that's important
there's many ways of doing this but
let's check it so right now we have our
lookup profile we're passing a Maki row
and we're trying to find the likes and
we're constantly logging the data and
pizza coding brownie points so what if
we passed in something else if we passed
in Sherlock a pass in last name
contact well that's working because I
spelled Sherlock wrong this is e so it's
good the way a good way to test that
Holmes and the last thing we'll check is
if we pass in a property that does not
exist I'll just say hello and no such
property so our function works
there is a simple way to create a random
decimal number in JavaScript it's with
the math dot random function so we have
this function here which is says random
function and it's returning zero
currently but we're gonna use the math
dot random function and you will see
that when I run this we have zero point
two three eight one three seven four one
and so on so it's always going to be a
number between zero and it could be zero
between zero and one but it could not be
one
often you want a random hole number
instead of a random decimal number that
can be accomplished with math dot floor
we have mat that floor here this rounds
down to the nearest whole number so we
pass in math dot random times 20 and
then we round down to the nearest whole
number this is going to create a random
whole number between 0 and 19 remember
math dot random can never be 1 it can be
0 but it can never be quite 1 so when we
multiply it by 20 we are going to get a
number between 0 and 20 but not
including 20 then we round down which
will end up being 0 to 19 so let me show
you another example where we're going to
get a random whole number between 0 & 9
it looks just like this so we're going
to modify this function so this math dot
random we're going to pass that into
math.floor so I have to put the
parentheses because we're passing it in
to that function and it's math dot
random times 10 and that's going to give
us a random number between 0 & 9 so if I
reload this you can see 9 5 4 1 every
time I load it it's a different random
number
you can also generate random whole
numbers within a range so look at this
function here our random range it takes
a minimum number and a maximum number
and then it just runs through this
calculation here so we have the math dot
random and we multiply it by the max
number minus the min number plus 1 and
then we get the floor which is rounding
down and we add all that to our minimum
number so this is just a calculation to
get a random number between the min and
Max so as practice I'm going to rewrite
it down here so we have the random range
and instead of our men and our max we
have my men and my max however the
equation is going to be the same so we
have math dot floor you can take a
chance to actually just look over the
equation and see if you can understand
how it works my max - my men and then we
just have to do plus one and then this
whole thing is going to be plus my men
so we already have this example test set
up down here random range between 5 and
15 and we're going to log it out here so
let's try that 11 6 7 see every number
is between 5 and 15 whenever I run it
another useful function is the parse int
function it takes a string and returns
an integer a lot of times you want to
make sure you're dealing with integers
and not strings for different
calculations and things like that
if the string cannot be converted into
an integer it returns in a in for not a
number so let me show you how it works
from this convert to integer function we
are going to return and we're going to
return the string except we're going to
convert it into an integer first so
we'll do parse int and then I'll pass in
the string now it was a string because
you can see here we're passing in the
string of the 56 but it's going to
return it as a number and integer
the person function can also be used
with a radix the radix specifies the
base of the number in the string such as
base 2 or base 7 or base 8 a base 2
would be binary so that's one of the
most common ones to use now the default
is base 10
that's what we use normally every day
but let me show you how that would work
we're gonna convert this number which is
a binary number to an integer so we'll
do return and I will do the parse and
I'll pass in this string as before but
now we'll have a second argument after
the comma which is going to be the
number 2 so and so the default of base
10 will be passing it as base 2 so the
computer knows that this is a binary
number
I love the ternary operator it's like a
one-line if-else expression now this is
what it looks like you have your
condition just like in an if statement
and then you would have a question mark
after the question mark you have what's
gonna happen if the condition is true
then you have a colon then you have
what's going to happen if the condition
is false so we can replace an if-else
statement like this into something using
the ternary operator so here we have
this if this condition is true we're
going to return true else we're going to
return false let's change this so now
we're going to use the ternary operator
so now it's just going to say return a
equals equals B that's the condition
then we use the question mark so if it's
true we're going to return true and then
we've have a colon and after the colon
we have what's going to happen if it's
false which is we're going to return
false
now I'm we honest you would never write
a line like this in real life because
you could just write return a equals
equals equals B and this lines actually
going to do the same thing as this line
however I just wanted to give you a
simple example of using the ternary
operator
one of the great things about
conditional or ternary operators is that
you can nest them within each other
which gives them even more power so
we're going to read write a function
here the function check sign and it's
going to return the string positive if
this number is positive negative if if
the number is negative or zero and we're
gonna use a nested conditional operator
so here it is return and first we're
going to check if num is more than zero
and then we'll use the ternary operator
if so the first thing after the question
mark is if it's true if it's true we're
gonna return positive if it's false if
the number is not more than zero we'll
do something else but here's where we're
going to have another ternary operator
we're gonna check if num is less than
zero so if the number is less than zero
well if that's true we have to have the
question mark for the ternary operator
if that's true we're going to return
negative and if it's false that's where
the colon comes in we're going to return
zero so let's do this check sign I'm
going to do a console about log so we
can see what this returns here and we
can see this is going to return positive
if we have a negative number here it's
going to return negative or if we have a
zero it's going to return zero now
you'll see that after this :
we have an entire ternary operator so if
this is true we just return positive if
it's false then we do everything here
which is another ternary operator where
it checks if this is true and if that's
true we return negative and if it's
false we to return zero
for a long time in JavaScript if you
were going to declare a variable you had
to use the VAR keyword but starting with
es6 in 2015 we can now declare variables
with let and Const as well over the next
few lessons I will be talking about what
let and constitute that it's different
than var but one of the things is that
let does not let you declare a variable
twice so let's look at this example we
have var cat name equals Quincy and then
down here var cat name equals Bo and if
I just run this code you'll see that
nothing is happening it's just allowing
us to set the cat name twice and to
clear it twice with the VAR keyword
however if we change this to let we're
gonna change all the var to let and
you'll see that when we load it again
you'll see an error
duplicate declaration cat name so this
is good that's creating this error
because you usually don't want to
declare a variable two times in the same
scope so this allows your program to
give you an error to tell you that
you've done something wrong now you can
still reset it so if we didn't use the
word let here we could just set the cat
name variable and now we're not gonna
get an error in this case we're
declaring the variable here to be Quincy
and we're setting the same variable to a
new name here this is one of the few
reasons that many people only use Latin
Const and never use var to declare
variables another thing in this code you
can see is use strict now this enables
strict mode which caches common coding
mistakes and unsafe actions so a lot of
people will use use strict at the top of
a full JavaScript file or maybe just in
a function to catch coding mistakes such
as if you create a variable and don't
declare it with varla a Const
another major difference between the var
and let keywords is that when you
declare a variable with var it is
declared globally or locally if declared
inside a function however let the scope
of let is limited to the block statement
or expression that it was declared in so
let's look at this example here if you
see this code we have this check scoped
function and we're calling it down here
and it's setting I with a var here of
our keyword - function scope then we're
setting it to block scope in here and
you can see it's console that logging
block scope eye is it says block scope
and we will get down here function scope
it's still block scope if we want this
to be function scope down here we're
going to have to use let so we would use
let here and then we would use let here
and if we run the code now you can see
in the console block scope eye is block
scope function scope eye is function
scope so even though we set I to block
scope here inside this block now a block
is just anything inside these squiggly
braces here so we set I inside this
block to block scope but then when we
get out here it's now back to function
scope because of this up here here's
another thing I want to show you if this
is if we comment this line out and we
change this to var what do you think is
gonna happen
well let's run and find out look we set
the var inside this block here to block
scope and it says block scope is block
scope but then when we're outside of the
block when we're outside of these
squiggly braces here we can still access
I here and it set the block scope but if
this was a let and we're declaring
inside this block if we run that now
when we get outside the block we get an
error because it's not defined
so that's another reason why people use
let instead of var is so that they can
make sure the variable is only defined
in the area they want to be defined in
but for now I'll uncomment this out
const is another way to declare a
variable it has all the features of left
but it's also read-only
you cannot reassign a Const so let's
look at this program here we're running
this print many times and it's going to
log out this sentence and the sentence
is up here vard sentence is declared and
then we reassign it here so first we
declare this sentence to be the string
is cool then it's reassigned to be the
string it's amazing so if we run that it
should work it prints free code camp is
amazing many times but if we change this
to Const let's see what happens
now I'll run this and we get an error
sentence is read only if you declare a
variable with the Const keyword you
cannot reassign it afterwards this can
be very helpful to prevent you from
accidentally making mistakes later if
you know for sure that you never want to
reassign a variable always use Const so
you don't accidentally reassign it when
you don't mean to another thing is when
you're using Const it's very common to
use all capital letters so like this
sentence like that and that's another
way to remember that it's a constant so
if I rename this year I'm also going to
have to repeat it here and while we're
at it we're gonna change this to left
because for the most part you should
only use Const or let but there are
certain circumstances where you would
use var and also in some other videos in
this course I'll be using var but in
your own code you should mainly use
Const and let let's reload this to see
what happens and it worked free code
camp is cool many times we can no longer
say that free code camp is awesome even
though we know it actually is
while you cannot reassign a variable
declared with Const you can mutate an
array so look at this example that's not
gonna work
first we declare the variable s and we
assign it to an array we declare with
Const and now we're gonna reassign the
variable s here but if we do that we're
gonna get the air s is read-only however
we can update the array using bracket
notation so I'll just comment that out
and using bracket notation I'll do index
0 I'll assign that to to index 1 I'll
assign that to 5 and then index 2 I'll
assign that to 7 and just like that it
is going to reassign the array so if I
just do a console dot log here console
dot log and put the array in there we
should see the new array here 2 5 7
as seen previously a Const declaration
alone doesn't really protect your data
from mutation if you have an object or
an array you can still mutate it even if
it's declared with Const there is
something called object dot freeze that
will prevent data mutation so let me
talk to you about object dot freeze
first of all let's understand this
function here we're using this function
to demonstrate object dot freeze so it's
going to create this constant math
constants with the PI in it this is an
object and right now this can still be
changed so if we look down here this is
a try-catch block will talk about
try-catch blocks in more detail later
but for now you just have to know that
it's going to try what's in the first
part of the block and if there's an
error then it's going to go into the
catch part and it's going to log it out
so right now we're going to try to
change math constants that pi to 99 and
if you can see right here we're going to
return the math that constants that pi
and down here we are doing into a
variable called pi so if we run this
you'll see that we console that log time
it's 99 but wait a second we don't want
pi to change because we know that pi
never changes that's why we're gonna use
object dot freeze so I'll put it right
here I'm gonna do object not freeze and
then in parentheses I'll put the object
which is math constants now I've frozen
math constants so when it tries to
change math constants top pi here it's
not going to work and it's going to go
into this catch block and it's going to
log out the ear or the exception so let
me run that and you'll see type air
cannot assign to read only probably a PI
of object so we had an error and we can
see here that pi is stays the same at
3.1
or so whenever you have an object and
you don't want any of the items in the
object to change use object dot freeze
this function here is called an
anonymous function it doesn't have a
name it is assigned to this variable
magic but there's no word right before
the function keyword to assign the name
to the function whenever you have an
anonymous function you can convert it
into an arrow function that makes it a
little quicker to write so instead of
the word function I'm going to take that
out completely and then put an arrow
here so this is the same thing except
it's just a little quicker to write but
we can shorten this even more if we're
just returning one value here we don't
even need the return keyword and we
don't need the curly braces so I can
delete all this and I can delete all
this here and now this is the full
function from before but it's just
really shortened up and to make this
even nicer we're not going to use var
and I change this to Const
just like in a normal function you can
pass arguments to arrow functions so let
me show you how to convert this function
into an arrow function so it's a normal
function now and it has two arguments
and then it's going to concatenate the
two arrays passed in so first we'll take
off the function keyword we're gonna
leave these parentheses with the
parameters now I'll put the arrow
since all we're doing is returning this
we don't even need the return keyword
and we don't need the curly braces so
I'll take that off we'll take this off
and now we've done this I just converted
that function into an arrow function and
it has these two parameters so we just
have the parameters and parentheses we
have the arrow and then we have what's
being returned right after the arrow so
if I run that you'll see that we
concatenate the two arrays that are
passed in in this example and then for
good measure we'll change this to
constant
arrow functions work really well with
higher-order functions such as map
filter and reduce I'll go into more
detail at a different time about map
filter and reduce but the main thing to
know is that they take functions as
arguments for processing collections of
data whenever one function takes another
function as an argument that's a good
time for an arrow function so what we're
going to do here is we're going to
update this function right here we want
to compute the square of only the
positive integers in the array so it's
passed in this array which is this and
we want to filter out everything that's
not a positive integer so I'm going to
use the filter and map functions to do
that but the main thing I want you to
look at is the arrow functions that I'm
passing in to filter a map this line is
going to be a lot more succinct because
of the arrow functions so we have the
squared integers is going to be the our
our and we're going to filter this so
dot filter now again I'm not really
gonna explain in detail what the filter
function does but that'll be something
for another time just look at this arrow
function we're gonna create this arrow
function am i starting it just like this
now before I showed you that you pass in
arguments in parentheses for an arrow
function but if you only have a single
argument like this the number argument
you don't need parentheses around the
argument you can just put the argument
and then the arrow so this is the
beginning of the arrow function and then
we'll see what's returned from the arrow
function first we want to filter this
array so we only have numbers that are
integers and numbers that are more than
0 so we'll do number that is integer and
then we will pass in the number and
number is more than 0 so let me complete
the parentheses here now the result of
this filter command will be an array
with all the numbers that are more than
zero and also integers so there'll be
442 and six but after we get that new
array we want to get the square of each
number in that array so that's where
we're going to use the map function now
the map function takes a function as its
argument but instead of writing a full
function out we can use an arrow
function so we're going to pass in X to
the function and there's gonna be an
arrow function now X just means every
element from the array that's being
passed to it
so remember the map is getting the array
for 42 6 X means for every element in
the array this is what we're gonna do to
it x times X because it's gonna be
squared again the main point of this
lesson is not to understand the filter
and math functions but to see that we
can put an arrow function we can pass in
an arrow function and it makes it so we
can fit everything really succinctly on
one line
so let's reload this and see if it works
now we have 16 1764 and 36
in order to create more flexible
functions you can use default parameters
the default parameter kicks in when the
argument is not specified or is
undefined so for instance with this
increment function we want to change it
we want to change the increment function
so you can pass in two arguments the
five and two to increment by 2 or you
can just pass in the 1 argument the 5 if
you want to increment by 1 so here the
numbers were passing in a number and a
value so we just have to put value
equals 1 so now if a value isn't passed
in it will be set to 1 automatically but
if it is passed in it will be set to
whatever is passed in so if we run this
we can look on the console we have 7 for
this first one and 6 for the second
the rest operator allows you to create a
function that takes a variable number of
arguments the rest operator is three
dots so we have this function here and
it's taking three arguments XY and Z and
it's summing them so at first it's
converting these XYZ into an array
called args and then it's reducing them
so it's summing them all up here and
then returning the result so right now
if we just run this it's going to log
six because one plus two plus three is
six but we can change this to use the
rest operator so we're still going to
pass in one two three but where it's
accepted here where we have the
arguments here XYZ I'm just gonna put
dot dot dot that's the rest operator
just dot dot dot and I'm going to put
args
so with this rest operator dot dot dot
it will convert everything that's passed
in into one array and the array is
called args so now we don't need this
anymore and it should work the same if
we run this we'll get six but we can
also now add any number of numbers so
I'll put a four on the end and ten it's
going to add those numbers together so
before we can only pass in three
arguments and now we can have any number
of arguments
the spread operator looks just like the
rest operator three dots but it expands
in already existing array or it spreads
out an array so it takes an array and
spreads out into its individual parts so
here we have an array with some months
and the spread operator can spread this
array that's our one into the individual
months instead of the actual array here
you can only use it in an argument to a
function or in an array of literal so
let's look at this so right now we're
setting array to two equal array one in
this example we're not actually copying
it because if we change array one if we
set the index of the array one two
potato and we log array two you'll see
that index zero is potato even though
we're logging array two and we only
change array one because these are equal
array two and array 1 are the same but
what if we want array to to be a copy of
array one we can use the spread operator
now we can't just use the spread
operator like this that's not gonna work
but if we put this inside brackets which
is an array it will spread out the
contents of array one into this new
array so we're not making array to equal
array one we are making array to equal
all of the contents of array one so
they'll be different so if we run this
again you'll see that it says January
for the first element and the array
instead of potato
the next few lessons will be about
destructuring assignment this is a
special syntax for neatly assigning
values taken directly from an object to
a variable so look at this object here
we have this object with three elements
we have the x y&z with their values and
it's all in the voxel variable so if we
want to take each individual element in
this object and assign it to its own
variable this is the old way of doing it
so you could do Vox without X to stores
X voxel that Y stores Y voxels at Z the
store Z now with with destructuring
there's a simpler and quicker way to
assign variables for each element in an
object so here's the destructuring
syntax right here this time we are
creating various a b and c and assigning
them to the values from the object x y
and z we can see we put in curly braces
here and we just say it equals the
object it equals a voxel you can read it
like this get the feel of X and copy
into the value a so get the feel of X
from the object copy into the value a
get the feel of Y from the object copy
into the value B get the feel of Z copy
it into the value C so this is just a
quicker way of assigning things from an
object into variables now we're going to
use the structuring to obtain the
average temperature for tomorrow from
the info object average temperatures so
we have average temperatures it has
today and tomorrow's temperatures and
then the average temperature is inputted
into this function here so I'm going to
change this line here to use
destructuring
and the structure the average
temperatures object here that's passed
into this function so first I'm just
going to put the average temperatures
variable here and then on this side of
the equal sign I'm going to have to use
two destruct
shirring so I'll put the curly braces
and we'll put tomorrow and the colon and
then the other curly brace so this is
saying get the tomorrow field from the
average temperatures object and assign
it to the temp of tomorrow variable so
if we run this we should see it says 79
in the console because we got the tempo
tomorrow variable we return temp of
tomorrow and it was logged right here so
we successfully used the structuring to
get the tomorrow variable out of average
temperatures
we can also use the structuring
assignment to assign variables from
nested objects we have this nested
object right here the local forecast and
inside we have some nested objects so we
have the forecast from today and the
forecast from tomorrow so here we have
get max of tomorrow where we're going to
pass in the forecast and here we can see
the local forecast becomes the forecast
variable and we're trying to figure out
the max of tomorrow so we are going to
use destructuring to figure that out so
it's going to equal forecast and
remember that is a nested object so here
when you're destructuring you're always
going to use the curly braces and we are
first going to get tomorrow and on the
other side of the colon we're gonna have
some more curly braces because it's
nested so we need to go inside of the
tomorrow object and we need the max so
we'll do max and then we have the colon
and max of tomorrow now we need two sets
of squiggly braces here so we have this
one and this one and so we've
destructured two times and the variable
is max of tomorrow so we've set the max
that was inside tomorrow to max of
tomorrow so if I run this you'll see
it's eighty four point six
you can use the structuring assignment
to assign variables from arrays look at
this example here so we have this array
of 1 2 3 4 5 6 and we're assigning the
variables Z and X to the first two
numbers of the array 1 & 2 the
difference between destructuring from
arrays and destructuring from objects is
that you cannot specify which element
from the array to go into a variable it
just goes in order however if we wanted
number 4 to be going to a variable we
could just do like this we would just
add some commas so we put a comma with
nothing in it like that two commas in
row and I'll put a Y here so now we have
the first element the second element we
skip the third element and then we have
the fourth element so if I console that
log z x and y we should see one two and
four here's another thing you can do you
can use the structuring of arrays to
switch the places of variables let me
uncomment out these and what I'm going
to do is use the structuring to switch
the places of a and B so it'll be like
this I'll say a B and I'll say equals B
a so now it's just taking this and
switching the places so instead a being
8 and B equals 6
it's now gonna log out 6 and 8 so let's
see yep it worked
we can use this structuring assignment
with the rest operator to reassign array
elements we can see in this example we
have this array that digits 1 through 10
and the array and we have this remove
first to function we're calling it here
and we're passing in the source that's
the source array and becomes the list so
we want to return the array with the
first two elements removed so let's use
the rest operator inside an array here
so we'll use the rest operator the three
little dots and to remove the first two
I just have to put two commas here with
nothing in between them so it's saying
do nothing for the first element do
nothing for the second element
everything else put into the our
variable we could have assign the first
two numbers in the array to two other
variables so I could do a B and then a
would be one B would be two and then R
would be an array of three four five six
seven eight nine ten but right now we
just need to return the array with the
first two elements missing so if I run
that you'll see that we did that if you
look in the console we've logged the
array and the first two elements are
missing and then we have the original
array down here
you can use the structuring assignment
to pass an object as a functions
parameter let me show you what I mean
right now we have this half function and
it's getting the stats argument so the
stats is being passed when it's called
down here and it's passing in this whole
object so this whole stats object but
you can see within this function we're
only using stats that Max and stats top
men so instead of passing the entire
stats into this function we can just
pass in what we need so this is what
we're gonna do I'm going to put in some
curly braces here and just put Max and
min so now when stats get passed in it's
D structured into just the max and min
variables and the max and min from the
function gets passed in so now instead
of doing stats that max we can just do
max and sort of stats that men we can do
men so if we reload that it's gonna work
exactly like it did before but now we
only pass in what we need this is
commonly used with API calls when you
are getting information from an ajax
request or an api request it will often
have a lot more information that what
you need and you can use destructuring
to get it down to what we actually want
to work with
template literals are a special type of
string that makes creating complex
strings easier you make them with this
backtick so here's an example of a
template literal right here we have the
beginning back tick and we have the
ending back tick this would be in place
of using a quotation a single or double
quotation mark a few advantages of using
these template literals these back ticks
instead of quotation marks are one you
can make multi-line strings you can see
this has two lines here's the first line
and here's the second line and if we log
the greeting is gonna put the new line
right in there another thing is you can
add quote single or double quotation
marks right in the string and you don't
have to escape them the third thing is
you can put variables right in the
string so if we see this see the dollar
sign and then we have these curly braces
and so anything in between these curly
braces that start with the dollar sign
is JavaScript so right now we just have
this variable person name which gets the
name from up here and then here we have
person that age which gets the age from
right there so it makes things easier
that you can put variables right in the
strings so if we run that you'll see
hello my name is zodiac as bro I am 56
years old and normally it would actually
also be printed with a newline but with
this exact code editor and console it
doesn't show the newline so there's
gonna be a coding challenge that we're
gonna do right down here we have this
make list function and we want it to
create a list based on the array that's
passed in so when we call make list we
pass and result that failure wellhere's
results result dot failure is this array
here and we want it to return an array
that looks like this
each element in the array is a template
literal that has some HTML in it and
then it also has this no var
on top and lime break that comes right
from this array that's passed in so
let's use template literal so to create
that so instead of setting this to equal
null I'm going to start this off to be
an empty array now there's many ways to
do this but I'm gonna use the classic
for loop so we'll do four and hopefully
you remember how to make a for loop will
you let I equal 0 while I is less than
our dot length and then at the end we
will increment I so inside this for loop
will do result display array dot push
and then here is where I'm going to use
the template literal put a back kick and
I'll put this HTML code here li class
equals text warning and now this next
part is going to be a variable because
it changes for each array element here
so I'm gonna do dollar sign and then the
curly braces and now I can just do R and
then at index I now in the curly brace
and then I can just put the /l I okay
and if we console dot log this out
because we just finished that video
console dot log result to display array
the array looks just like it's supposed
to be if you look in the console it
returns correctly
es six added some nice support for
easily defining object literals if we
look at this function here this function
is an arrow function it takes in three
variables name age and gender and it's
going to return an object and the object
is going to have a series of key value
pairs where the key is
the name age and gender and the values
are the past in variable names the past
end names
age and gender so if you look in the
console you can see what this currently
does we did the create person we passed
a name age and gender and you can see in
the console the object is name and
zodiac as bro age 56 gender male so you
can see there's some repetition we're
repeating name name age age gender
gender now the first name is the key in
the second name is the value but there's
a way to just make this simpler if you
know that you want to create an object
with where the key is the name of the
variable and the value is the value of
the variable there's an easier way to do
it we can actually delete this whole
thing here and that's how we're gonna do
do it we'll just do name age gender on
the script knows that it's going to
return this object and it's going to
have three key value pairs the name age
and gender so if I reload this you'll
see in the console it looks exactly the
same because this code does the same
thing that the previous code did
an object can contain a function this is
the long way to put a function within an
object but there is a simpler way we
have the set gear function but instead
of using the function keyword and this
colon we can just delete all that and
now this is the new way if I load this
again you'll see three in the console
just like it was before because we've
been able to set the gear using that
function
yes six provides a syntax to help create
objects using the class keyword so
here's the older way to create an object
it's with the the new keyword we can
instantiate an object using this new
keyword and we're instantiating the
Space Shuttle object we have to have
this constructor function up here so we
use this to construct the object where
we pass in the target planet Jupiter and
we set the target plan to this dot
target planet once we create the new
object like this that allows us to do
Zeus dot target planet so Zeus target
planet which we set to Zuppa der Jupiter
so in the console you can see Jupiter
the class syntax replaces the
constructor function creation so I
believe that we're going to use the
class syntax so I'll do a class space
shuttle and then we have the curly brace
here and so inside here we have a
constructor so du constructor or get
planet and then that's all we just have
to put in the curly brace and this works
exactly the same as before using the
class keyword and this constructor so
down here we are going to do the same
thing for a vegetable class so for the
vegetable class we'll have class that's
the bowl and we're going to have a
constructor with the name this that name
equals name so now that we have this we
can set this vegetable to make class
which will return a vegetable class
that's up here and then when we do new
vegetable and passing carrot this carrot
will go into here and it'll get set as
this that name so when we console that
log here at that name
we should get carrot
with a class object you often want to
obtain values from the object and set a
value of a property within an object
these are often called getters and
setters so in this class object we have
the constructor which we already talked
about we also have a getter and setter
to get and set the writer so we can get
the writer and we can set the writer
getter functions are meant to simply
return or get the value of an object's
private variable to the user without the
user directly accessing the private
variable so the private variable is this
underscore author that gets set when you
construct the object and then when we do
get writer it's gonna return this down
underscore author so you never actually
interact directly with this variable but
it's going to get the writer which is
the author here and when you're setting
it's the same so you're never
interacting with underscore author but
you can set that with the writer setter
this change could invoke calculations or
even even overriding the previous value
completely so you can have any number of
code lines in this setter to ultimately
maybe do different calculations before
you set it or a calculation before you
get the property so what we're gonna do
is make your own getter and setter for
the thermostat class we're gonna create
a thermostat class and we're gonna have
a getter and setter so here's the thing
about this challenge is that when we
construct the class it's going to accept
Fahrenheit temperature but we're going
to create a getter and setter in the
class to obtain the temperature in
Celsius so it's gonna have to do the
calculation right within the class so
let's do that we're going to do a class
of thermostat and in this class we need
the constructor but when you first
create the thermostat you're going to
pass in a temperature and remember this
is going to be Fahrenheit now within
this constructor we're going to set a
private variable this dot underscore
temp so the word
this just means that this variable is
only accessible within this class here
and the underscore temp whenever you
start a variable with an underscore
that's going to generally signify that
it's a private variable that you're not
supposed to access it outside of that
scope or outside of that class so we're
gonna set the temp and we're not going
to just put this underscore temp equals
temp because it's passed in as a
Fahrenheit and we want to convert it to
Celsius I just happen to have the
equation for Celsius so it's five over
nine times and then with temp minus
thirty-two so now we can create the
getter and setter so we'll forget it
will you get temperature and we're just
going to return this dot underscore temp
which now it's in Celsius because we're
storing the value in Celsius even though
the thermostat is created in Fahrenheit
so with the setter it's going to be the
same set temperature updated temp and
it's now going to still be in Celsius so
this dot temp equals updated temp so
let's look at the code down here how
we're using it so the consular Mesilla
equals mate class this mate class
function is going to return this
thermostat object here and then we're
going to do a constant thermos equals
new thermostat so when you're
instantiating an object you always use
the new keyword new thermostat that's
this and we're passing in 76 that goes
into the constructor the temp and so we
do this calculation to convert that
Fahrenheit to the Celsius in this local
variable here and then let temp equals
thermal temperature
so thermostat temperature is going to
use the getter get temperature and it's
going to return this down underscore 10
so a key thing to look at is that there
are no parentheses after this so
generally if there's if something is a
function you would see parentheses after
the function name but if it's a variable
or property name it's going to not have
parentheses so getters and setters are
access similar to properties and then we
can use the setter here
thermostat temperature equals 26 and
then it sets it with the updated
temperature and now we can say temp
equals thermos temperature and if we do
a console dot log here we can do that
with the temp and it should have the new
temperature if I load that 26
in the past people would use the require
function to import functions and code
from other files but now we have import
and export you can export code in one
file and then import it in another file
it also allows you to only import
certain functions from a file or certain
variables let me show you how it works
so in this file we have this capitalized
string function we're passing in the
string hello and we want to log out the
capitalized strings but right now it
just has an error because there is no
capitalized string function in this file
however in this other file we do have a
capitalized string function in this
string function GJ s we have export this
is the export statement I was talking
about and then it's exporting this
function it's actually a variable
capitalized string that's set to equal a
function this is a an arrow function
where we pass in a string and then we
return the string dot to uppercase now a
to uppercase is just a string function
that makes every letter uppercase so we
can import this in our other file so
let's go back to our other file and I
will import and with the import
statement you're going to use curly
braces and then I'll put capitalized
string and then we have to say what
we're importing it from we want to
import it from and this is where I put
the file name now normally you're going
to start with a dot slash which just
means the current directory and I'll
type in the file name string function
now the file name is a dot a yes after
it but that's assumed so you don't have
to put yes you can just put the file
name without the extension so if I run
this you can see hello in all capital
letters is successfully imported this
function from the other file and we used
it in this file
I talked a little bit about export in
the last lesson but now I'm going to go
into more detail you export functions
and variables from one file so that you
can import them into another file that's
how you can reuse different code so we
have this function here this is a
capitalized string function it actually
just capitalizes the first letter of the
string and then leaves the rest of the
string lowercase and before I showed you
you can just put export right before
here but we can explore a different way
so I'll do export and then in curly
braces capitalized capitalized string
and so now we've just explored this
function and to export a variable like
this we have Constable's barkas
particles foo to export these variables
you just type an export like both before
so now in this file we're exporting this
function and these two variables and
then we could import them into another
file
if a file exports multiple different
things you can import each things
individually or you can import
everything so let me show you how you
would import everything from a file
it's just import and then you're going
to put an asterisk or a star and then
you're gonna put as import as and then
you have to create an object to store
everything in so I'm gonna import stuff
from a file called capitalized strings
so I'm going to call this capitalized
strings so this could really be anything
I'm creating an object with this and
then I'm going to say what I'm importing
it from from and then I just put the
file name in this case it's just going
to be capitalized strings sometimes you
would have to put a dot slash if it's in
the same directory there and then I'll
make sure to put a semicolon at the end
so if you're importing everything you
always start off with import star as and
then this can be anything it can be at
any object name that you create and
they're going to put from and then you
put the file name in quotation marks
just like that
before when I talked about exports I was
talking about named exports there's also
something called an export default this
is a fallback export and it's often used
if you only want to export one thing
from a file so if you let's say I want
this to be my fallback export I'm just
going to only export this one thing from
the file I can just put export default
so now we know that this is just the the
fallback though basically just the one
thing we're going to export from this
file
so we talked about exporting a default
export now I'm going to show you how to
import a default export it's pretty much
the same as before but there is a slight
difference so we are going to pretend we
have a file called math functions that
has a default export name subtract so
let me show you how you would import
that so it's going to be import subtract
and we've already reached the difference
here if it's not a default export you'll
put curly braces around this but it is a
default export so we are not going to
use curly braces but we still have to
say what it what it's from
so from math functions okay so that is
how you would import a default export
well thanks for watching don't forget to
subscribe and remember use your code for
good